foreign
[Music]
so
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves with george callaway
only on sputnik radio
so it's a rise queen camilla did anybody
ask you
there'll be a few people in britain have
uh
paused for breath at that somewhat
audacious request from her majesty we
mean in the
due course of time of course long life
to queen elizabeth but i think it's time
when in the course of events she finally
passes
many years from now i hope i hope she
gets to send a 100th birthday telegram
to herself
but we're going to have to confront the
fact
that nobody chose king charles
still less queen camilla
mind you
sarkier star is revealed in an exclusive
video just breaking on social media that
he long campaigned for the abolition of
the monarchy
i'm with keith actually but only after
her majesty dies and
should we believe a united states deep
state
about ukraine
on the very day
of that call in power at the united
nations
2003 held up that vial
to the world
it was a vile lie
should we believe them now
and on this very day
the rump parliament passed a resolution
in 1649
for the abolition of the monarchy
should we
begin that debate again
all kinds of issues on the table this
evening including the war in yemen i'd
say it was a forgotten war but nobody
knew about it in the first place it's
the mother of all talk shows this
radio sputnik
we speak your language
of all talk shows the only education you
can get for free
[Music]
george galloway
this is
radio sputnik
now sarkir upon being made a queen's
council when your hair was right dark
you said on video
it's ironic you're a queen's council as
you had long campaigned for the
abolition of the monarchy
do you still stand by that sir
of course a knighthood can make a big
difference kierstarma the so-called
leader of the so-called labour party is
outed this very day as a republican or
at least he was
but he has a point doesn't he surely in
the 21st century
i
my eyes opened wide
this morning when i saw that her majesty
the queen god bless her cotton socks
has called on us
you may say commanded us
to accept camilla as the queen
in the jew course of events of course
i can't accept that i can't accept that
charles will be the king
because i never picked him and i don't
fancy him at all
i don't fancy him to stay out of
politics and i think his politics are
zany to be
kind
and generous as is my usual
want
i don't want king charles interfering in
parliamentary affairs i don't want him
interfering with his walk hug a husky
talk to the trees green
manias i don't want him to do that i
don't want to have to pay for him to do
that and pay him a very great deal of
money indeed
i want to have a grown-up country once
her majesty the queen has passed i want
a referendum on what we need to do about
britain's governance whether we should
continue the monarchy at all
and if we should continue it on what
terms should we continue it why can't we
pick
princess anne
instead of prince charles to be the next
monarch if we are to have one do you see
where i'm going here a grown-up country
a mature democracy has a right to decide
who will be its head of state
i'm not arguing for an elected president
although if there is one i'll run for it
i'm arguing for
a
purely
titular
head of state like the president of
ireland for example like the president
of germany for example with no political
power of any kind and no right to
interfere in the political process in
any way
the parliament could pick the
head-off state
a senate instead of the house of lords
could pick the head of state
for everyone who says to me what do you
fancy president tony blair
tony blair would never run for that
office because then you'd know how much
money he was earning and from where he
was earning it
on this day in 1649
uh the rump parliament
of oliver cromwell
passed the resolution to
discontinue the system of
monarchy that was in 1649
isn't it time that we in britain had a
grown-up conversation about this subject
nobody asked me if camilla should be
queen but i'm asking you in the poll
that we've got running now should
camilla be queen a yes b
no it'll be interesting to see how that
comes up
i think that the british will be ready
for such a referendum i may very well
lose it although i'm quite good at
fighting referenda as you know i won in
scotland i won
over brexit and i'll campaign with all
my heart for a grown-up democratically
chosen
head of state for britain i may lose it
i probably will lose it
but
at least we'll have had a say
on who is
to be entitled to call themselves our
head of state
just my view let me know
on the polls on social media and by
calls what you think we should do about
it also on this day or in the last day
or two
somebody called general colin powell
now deceased
who was then the united states secretary
of state
actually went to the united nations and
told a pack of lies
so
portentous
so momentous
so murderous
that i hope he now resides
in the fires of hell
because colin powell's lie that iraq had
weapons of mass destruction
in volumes
when even this vial
could wipe out new york city or whatever
else
he said
it doesn't get more serious than that
and of course it was echoed
by that friend of liberty
playing jack straw
still playing because having been caught
in a chinese takeaway
by channel four's dispatchers with a
camera up their jumper
selling himself
to
a fictitious company
to the highest bidder
for 5 000 pounds a day
jack straw
our foreign secretary and colin powell
the united states's
foreign secretary told a pack of lies
that can scarcely be
exaggerated
because a million people are dead
because of it
a million people
imagine that
how high a pile of corpses
that would be
that's what colin powell did on this day
all those years
ago
but i'm asked to believe
the current incarnations
of colin powell
and
jack straw
when they tell me
that russia
is imminently
about to invade ukraine
and the disturbing thing for me
is that so many people
who know that they were lied to
by the same liars that are lying to them
now
are ready to believe
this latest generation
of lies
and the latest generation
of liars that's truly disturbing to me
you know einstein said that
doing the same thing over and over again
and expecting a different result
is a sure sign
of insanity
yet so many of our people
are insanely
falling
for the same old lies
often times from the same old liars
certainly from the same
broadcasters and newspapers that lied to
them before
and are lying to them now about russia
lying to them now about china
but who have fallen for it
over again as the who put it don't get
fooled again and i honestly thought
that more of our people
would have learned their lesson
than plainly have done so because i see
it
in my voluminous correspondence
on social media
where i have millions of followers who
send me thousands of messages tens of
thousands of messages
and it's quite plain
that many of our people
are literally sheep
being led
by the same
old suspects
into the same old pen
of war
and destruction the new york times
which told us that powell
was telling the truth then
are telling us that biden and blinken
are telling the truth no
even though
biden was a liar then and is a liar now
i'm looking on my screen
at blinken
denouncing russia
for banning the german broadcaster
deutsche weller
without a single reference to the fact
that this is in retaliation
to germany banning
rt
in german
how can people write that stuff with a
straight face
and how can people be so stupid
but to
swallow it up that's what i'm
asking
myself
i'm asking
myself why we should boycott
joe
rogan
in the united states
but we should take money from
saw bones himself
the crown prince of saudi arabia
who soared
a washington post columnist
into pieces i'm wondering why
we should boycott
the winter olympics in china
but embrace the world cup in qatar i'm
wondering
why you're all so
stupid out there
that you cannot see
the contradictions in all of this
these lies
that you keep
falling for them
over and over and over
again
and then there's boris
johnson
he's got a new broom
he's sweeping out the old in downing
street although whether
all of them
had to be pushed
before they jumped
is a moot point
but he's just appointed
as his head of communications
gito hari
as third division bbc presenter
who failed to make it
at gb news
as his head of communications to sort
all of boris johnson's problems out
in britain
even though gito harried just a couple
of months ago
described boris johnson
as sexually incontinent
and dragging the conservative party and
britain to destruction
the same gito hari that was a lobbyist
for huawei
which we have banned in britain on
national security grounds the same gito
hari
that was a campaigner
to remain in the european union
when boris johnson's entire shtick
is that he got brexit
done guitar wants to take britain back
into the european union just like
this block of wood
just like
the bbc
and the liberal media and virtually
every
working journalist in britain
today just like virtually every
broadcaster in britain today
talk about clasping an asp
onto your breast
if boris johnson thinks that gito hari
is the answer it must be a very stupid
question
but the real question
is this
in this sea of troubles
in which we are afloat
at home and abroad
is there anyone serious out there
that think boris johnson
or keir starmer
are the answer is there anyone who
believes
that this ram shackled dysfunctional
utterly failing state of ours
is the best that we can be
we are the people that invented
the steam engine
but i arrived just in the nick of time
for this show tonight
because of an utterly calamitously
mismanaged
underinvested
hodgepodge
heath robinson
railway system in britain
in 2021
our gas prices are about to triple
and this man's labor party
wants
our energy sector to remain in the hands
of the vulture capitalists who snapped
it up when it was privatized
he opposes the return
of energy of water of railways back into
public ownership
is there anyone who believes
that this is as good
as it could be for us
our people is a great people
our industrial revolution transformed
the world
our inventors our engineers
our builders our shipbuilders our miners
our nuclear technicians
our fintech technicians our artists
our musicians
our writers our language
we were kings once
now
we're waiting for charlie
to be our next monarch fasten your seat
belts it's going to be a bumpy ride
tonight
it's the mother of all dog shows
[Music]
there is no trick other than hard work
creativity care and recognizing
that duty is more important than love
the booming voice of robert maxwell an
arrogant man who used his publishing
empire to gain empower and influence
but in this shocking account never told
before in this way george galloway
recalls his first encounter with maxwell
it looked like a grizzly bear
advancing towards me
and punches me with these giant fists
like sides of ham right in the solar
plexus so hard that i literally bent
double
then after george exposed maxwell as a
crook in parliament
it was war
every one of his papers the daily mirror
then following the sunday mirror the
sunday people the daily record then a
few days later the sunday mail in
scotland even the european
which he then owned
all
over galloway
scottish daily news journalist ron mckay
was there
every night
presumably when they had a drink in them
he would boom over the tunnel
about the
the the the cretins the fools
but the majority of the workforce
believed that he would take over and
their jobs would be secure but of course
he didn't he just disappeared and then
the millionaire newspaper publisher
robert maxwell is dead
what really happened did robert maxwell
jump or was he pushed
it could be that he went out to as he
did
maturate over the side of the boat
i'm with glenn maxwell in that i leaned
towards the mortar this is maxwell the
monster you said what is my
secret i will let you when your viewers
know it and what it is i'm not attached
to property
consequently losing or gaining it means
nothing to me
george galloway
and the mother of all talk shows join us
at the college of knowledge where there
are no tuition fees
i love that word mick jerry there's a
whole lot of maturation going on now
though i say so myself it is a pretty
good series it's groundbreaking uh my
editor and long time friend my oldest
friend ron mackay and i maxwell the
monster
he stole
ron mccow's pension which is not the
reason i was against them but it's one
of the reasons the series is called
maxwell the monster it's a three-part
car you can get it now on patreon it's
only four pound to become a supporter
and the amount of content that's coming
down the pipe on my patreon page has to
be seen to be believed and will shortly
be seen for example my audiobook history
of the 1970s
which i lived
i know i don't look old enough but
actually i became rather prominent in
the 1970s and it was one hell of a
decade
if a decade could sue for defamation it
would be the 1970s it was a great time
to be
alive
that audiobook
is coming
for just four pound along with all the
other continent all the other uh content
to be
uh on patreon uh so it's www dot
e patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com forward slash george galloway
please uh do it tonight now if you were
trying to watch on facebook apologies
there were some technical problems mr
algorithm was in about our ribs but we
are now broadcasting everywhere as
normal so if you're watching on facebook
now please share
the stream
now
enough from me
let's hear from our first guest
andrew koribko is an american political
analyst who specializes in u.s russia
relations a pretty important time to be
specializing in that andrew welcome uh
to the mother of all talk shows uh in my
opening remarks i said that i didn't
believe a word that the american deep
state had to say
because i've been there before
uh once bitten twice shy and all of that
was i being too harsh
well you you know i want to thank you
for bringing me on the show uh in my
personal assessment the united states
deep state cannot be trusted they have a
track record of being very unreliable
outright lying and manipulating the
facts as we're all speaking about us
russian relations and specifically the
very tense situation eastern ukraine we
need to remember what the local dome
boss militia leaders have said they've
been consistently warning
that there could be a false flag attack
now obviously that's not going to be by
the russian federation according to them
it would be staged by kiev or kiev's u.s
led western intelligence agency allies
so i believe that the situation is
actually just as bad as you said that uh
you were definitely not too harsh on
them you actually had a pretty realistic
assessment because the situation is
tense and is very serious i think
everyone has the right to be very
concerned well i've said from the
beginning andrew that russia will not
invade ukraine but ukraine might invade
those areas of eastern ukraine
populated overwhelmingly by russian
people many of them russian citizens
in
absolute breach of the
minsk agreement which they signed
that these areas could have autonomous
status within ukraine
other signs that that might be happening
yes we do see those signs according to
both russia and the donbass militias
ukraine he has assembled over 100 000
forces across the line of contact and
there has been an uptick in shelling
what's very i never read that andrew i
keep reading about 100 000 russians
masked in russia
but i've never heard the figure a
hundred thousand ukrainian forces
on the
line of division inside ukraine
yes and one of the reasons why this is
so concerning is because russian
intelligence has warned that if kiev is
encouraged by its u.s led western
patrons to uh initiate a third round of
civil war hostilities in donbas this
wouldn't just be a humanitarian disaster
and it would also be a military one of
course but it could serve as the pretext
for the united states to uh deploy
strike missiles to the region and
russian intelligence is also very
concerned that these might potentially
be hypersonic missiles now because the
risk is assessed is very credible that's
why president putin made the decision to
publicize russia's security guarantee
proposals at the end of december and
these proposals have thus far served as
the basis of russian american and
russian nato diplomacy over the past uh
six weeks or so
so i believe to answer your question
could there be some type of attack i
believe that there are forces in the
united states the american deep state
and to clarify what i mean by that i
refer to the deep state as america's
permanent military intelligence and
diplomatic uh bureaucracies and there
are different policy making factions
within there in particular the
anti-russian deep state faction the
united states has an interest in
provoking the scenario
not only so that they can have their uh
enemy number one so to speak for nato to
rally around granted that's not working
so well i mean some nato countries are
not on board with this we see the german
example
for instance but they also hope that by
doing this the united states so-called
pivot to asia to more aggressively
contain china can be stopped and
redirected back towards russia so you
kind of have these two factions the
anti-russian and anti-chinese deep state
factions vying over which of these two
great powers should they prioritize
containing donald trump wanted to focus
on china but now and biden seemed like
he wanted to focus on china too up until
the past few months when this
anti-russian faction seemed to have
been backed up to their old tricks and
we see the situation now it's very
serious russian intel is very concerned
president putin is directly involved we
have this high level negotiations and uh
that's uh presently the state of affairs
right now
let me walk that back um
i can understand
uh at least two reasons why
the united states confrontation with
china could be acute one is that
the chinese political economic system
is uh
a competitor a contender uh for
the way forward for the world
it's a communist country ruled by a
communist government and therefore
you could say it's
it's an existential threat to
the american way
but russia is
a capitalist
european
white
christian
country
why would
that be
enemy number one for the united states i
just don't get that andrew
okay so well i've actually been putting
a lot of thought into that as well over
the past few years and my conclusion is
that uh it's precisely because despite
the cultural and socio-economic and
historical commonalities with russia
russia still maintains its sovereignty
russia is very fiercely independent and
uh under president putin's tenure and
he's been in office for over 20 years
now one capacity or another russia has
really risen from its knees and russia
has made sure that it's able to defend
its interest and i'm not just speaking
broadly about interest here i'm talking
about socioculturally they're very much
against hyperliberal values being
imposed upon a traditionally majority
conservative traditional population
despite being uh involved in the western
type of capitalist system they still
want to preserve national sovereignty
they don't want transnational
corporations dictating policy taking
control of strategic resources and
pretty much what we see is russia sets
an example
that i believe the us is concerned that
other countries that are also culturally
and historically similar in europe they
might feel emboldened by this they might
feel like they want to flex their own
national sovereignty and quite curiously
we're not going to have enough time to
go down this rabbit hole here poland is
in a way in its own way kind of
following in russia's footsteps granted
they are anti-russian the core when it
comes to regional policies but the
ruling law and justice party which is
comprised of nationalist conservatives
they have been
in their own way trying to advance what
the ruling party understands to be
poland's national domestic interest and
to that end they have been undertaking a
broad range of reforms specifically in
the judicial sphere and the media's fear
granted they will never say they're
influenced by russia and they're
obviously doing this independently on
their own but i do think it's very
interesting that you have two countries
that are at odds but domestically
although it's an imperfect comparison
you already see this effect of russia
having been the last bastion of national
sovereignty on the continent for the
most part having actually now having
some different peers you also have
hungary of course but i find the polish
example particularly interesting because
most people wouldn't think of poland as
under its uh current leadership as
flexing national sovereignty credentials
and everything but that's precisely what
we have right now of course again we
don't really have the time to go into it
but i encourage the audience to kind of
do their own research and try to do some
comparisons between the two i find the
comparisons to be quite interesting well
of course it isn't just poland and
hungary
bulgaria has
opted out basically of the
of biden's response to the ukraine
crisis slovakia at least in the form of
its president did and now the president
of the czech republic has done the same
thing and most importantly as you uh
alluded earlier
germany is very definitely not on board
and even france
uh is making independent noises about
the need for a european
security
architecture which is not prey to
uh these madcap decisions from
washington but
as you say we don't have unlimited time
so let me
pivot to asia
one of the consequences of
this
duality
of confronting russia and china at the
same time
is to ensure that russia and china
are almost now one
economically speaking
i think increasingly militarily also
certainly diplomatically
their geopolitical
worldview is the same
the chinese president said this week
in the company of putin
we are not allies we are much more than
allies
this is the law of unintended
consequences isn't it for american
policy
yeah i would go as far as saying that
when the united states attempted to
simultaneously contain russia and china
around 2014 we saw what happened with
euro maidan in ukraine and that's around
the time the us stepped up its
provocations in the south china sea that
uh unintended consequences you rightly
put it only push those two together
granted their grand strategies were
already converging but the united states
is unprovoked aggressions against both
serve to accelerate that process and
with reference to president putin's
latest trip to beijing that really was
globally game changing because now
everybody sees that uh their grand
strategies are fully aligned
they are definitely working together as
one with one another to synchronize the
russian-led eurasian uh economic union
and the chinese belt and road initiative
this is going to unlock eurasia's entire
economic potential we also see a lot of
other world leaders were also in beijing
and they're meeting with president xi
and other chinese dignitaries so what
we're left with is the conclusion that
with the united states first of all it
should not even try to contain anybody
the united states should have tried to
truly work with these countries and find
a way to peacefully coexist and mutually
benefit in particular through economic
financial and technological cooperation
ecological cooperation and other manners
in order to facilitate the irreversible
emerging multi-polar world order but
because they bid off more than they can
chew i mean they shouldn't even try to
concentrate in only one country but by
trying to concentrate on both great
powers which they pretty much serve as
the dual engines of this emerging
multi-polar world order all they did was
accelerate the same process they wanted
to indefinitely stop and it seemed like
under trump the american deep state
concluded that they're gonna focus on
china biden seemed to kind of pick up
the baton for almost i'd say about first
nine to ten months of his presidency but
now the us is trying to redirect back
towards russia and this deep state is
just this deep state is very confused
and we see that i mean europe sees that
asia sees that uh india used to be
regarded as on board with anti-chinese
containment plans nobody can any longer
make that as an objective assessment
india actually hosted president putin in
early december and they signed a
99-paragraph strategic partnership
declaration to reaffirm their existing
strategic partnership so that whole
indo-pacific policy of containing china
to the quad it's not working that's why
they want to replace with august what
we're seeing is they're narrowing down
these
american-led military alliances and you
had mentioned the european front
and as we see i mean nato itself is
fractured in the asia pacific the
american led alliance system it's not
working as the united states intended
united states is confused nobody can
rely on it we saw what happened in
afghanistan it was very shameful
shameful evacuation i mean nobody
expected a country that declares itself
a unipolar hegemon to be defeated like
that and so swiftly by the taliban i
think right now america is experiencing
a crisis of confidence it's unsure of
what it wants to do and the whole world
sees that but because it's so confused
it's also trying to destabilize the
world trying to create a so-called
scorched earth policy out of desperation
hoping that it can find opportunities in
the chaos and that's why this current
ukrainian crisis which is really a u.s
russian missile crisis is very very
dangerous
dangerous indeed uh finally andrew um
what should we conclude from all of this
is america run by idiots
okay well but i think i think that these
people
each faction is very clever in their own
way they're very pernicious and they're
very cunning but the problem in the
american system is because these two
factions anti-chinese and anti-russian
granite the two factions themselves are
the problem but accepting that they're
unlikely to ever disappear anytime soon
the very fact that they're so fiercely
competing with one another is creating a
lot of chaos i mean you use the word uh
unintended consequences and we see these
unintended consequences aren't just
globally on the geostrategic level
they're also domestically in the united
states the u.s u.s anti-russian deep
state war against former president trump
totally destabilized the united states
and we saw a couple years ago the unrest
that in my personal assessment was
encouraged by democrats for political
self-serving reasons ahead of the 2020
elections with anti-fun black lives
matter that wasn't just a color
revolution that was a spree of urban
terrors and that was actually in its own
way a hybrid were on america by
americans in some ways and we see that
are they idiots are they super geniuses
well they think they're the smartest
guys in the room they aren't are the
idiots well there's a lot of idiots
among them but i'm more concerned about
the devious ones that are really trying
to divide rule and destroy because
they're so desperate not only to cling
to power but they delusionally in my
view think they can expand their power
not only abroad
but also at home with america divided
and the u.s is foreign policy divided
it's very unclear what's going to happen
but i'm cautiously optimistic that this
russian chinese and times will serve as
a stabilizing force in eurasian and
global affairs and that what just
recently happened over the past few
months putin in india putin and china
this is a game changer rick rush india
china if they can uh work out some of
their differences and there are some
trade and border differences between
india and china i'm confident that we
will actually live and see this emerging
multipolar world order i mean it's
developing in front of our eyes but it's
moving faster than ever and that's
precisely because of the law of
unintended consequences and masterful
leadership by uh president xi and
president putin
andrew i'm sure i'm not alone uh in the
audience in thinking you to be
an exceedingly clever young man and
astoundingly eloquent to boot uh how do
people follow your work
well you could follow me on twitter my
handle was a caripco
k-o-r-y-b as in boy ko they could follow
me on twitter i'm on facebook and i'm
also on telegram and the russian uh
social media site vkvk.com
fantastic i i really hope that we get to
speak together again and uh before long
thanks very much andrew for coming on
the show should camilla be queen yes 46
no
isn't that interesting
700 votes cast
so if you can
please
uh
make sure that you vote on my twitter on
my youtube on my telegram uh
let's see if we can get this to a big
and representative
number but i'm i'm actually
really surprised at that result yes
camilla should be queen 46
no she should not
and by the way it's increasing
that
that margin on youtube it's yes only 25
no
75 percent and on telegram yes 24
percent
no
76 percent
my goodness
g whiz right first question of the
evening on this day in which year did
the queen ascend to the throne 1950
answer after the break
for me
radio sputnik
[Music]
just remember back in 2002 2003
there was a wish by george bush for
regime change that's what was driving
him
nothing to do with weapons of mass
destruction which of course didn't exist
in iraq so they had to construct some
sort of formula some sort of cover story
in order to persuade the british public
that intervention in iraq was right now
david kelly
as an expert in weapons of mass
destruction knew
that
this was untrue he knew that there were
probably no weapons of mass structure in
iraq
that was a guy that could have brought
down i was going to brought down the
whole system
i reckon you're a chat you've been
thrown up to deve to our probing
the foreign affairs select committee
that
parliamentarian briefing i think that
was an indignity to him
we saw it on the news and my very first
thought was shock
oh my god you know this man is in the
eye of the media hurricane
he should be protected by that at
over least
i don't know
the details of how lord hutton happened
to be selected but what was certainly
the case is that he was the right kind
of judge to use from the point of view
of dining street and the intelligence
services as well after 21 days of
hearing
only one half of one day
was spent on discussing the forensic
aspects
that is disgusting
we were given the hutton report the day
before it was published but
actually what happened was
he went too far
the events of 2003
were disgraceful ones in this country's
history and his unfinished business
those responsible for an illegal war
those responsible for the death of david
kelly have not been brought to justice
there's been no inquest into david
kelly's death
there needs to be one
we need to make sure that those who
behaved in a reprehensible way in 2003
are finally brought to book
and don't forget you can
get from amazon
the killing kelly dvd and you can
download it on
vimeo
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have as long as you have
questions we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik
telling the untold
well mathematicians amongst you will
have worked out that it was 1952
exactly 70 years ago a truly remarkable
stint at the
wicket i must say
no one could possibly have imagined back
in 1952 that in
that queen elizabeth would still be
not just on the throne but working uh
should camilla though be queen
uh that's the question we're asking on
my twitter feed on my youtube and on my
telegram uh so let me give you the phone
numbers at this point if you're calling
from the united kingdom remember it's
completely free it's 08081
if you're in the united states it's also
completely free and that includes canada
by the way it's plus one eight four four
nine four four double three double four
you can email the show anytime at on air
at motes dot tv
now uh
liverpool and uh
oxford coming up uh
i think that there's uh yeah there's the
liverpool one now let me explain i think
there's only two standard seats left
but there are
uh vip tickets still available i'm not
sure how many i think about 17 18
something like that it's a while off but
there's every chance if you don't get
your tickets uh very soon that there
might not be any seats up for you so
that is in the hope street theater and
then we're coming to oxford town don't
forget that oxfordshire was where it all
happened
dr david kelly's most mysterious death
and we're at oxford town hall some of
the
best public events i've spoken at in my
life have been in oxford
both at the oxford union and in oxford
town hall in the run-up to the iraq war
if you
have come to hear me before or if you're
interested in the kelly issue if you're
interested in the iraq war and you're in
oxford or surrounds it's in oxford town
hall there's the uh situation there now
i've got quite a lot as you can imagine
of social media earth person says should
camilla be queen
no she's not german enough that's very
funny by the way
snow tannin wolf says camila capello
if she dost repenteth for her woke-tard
sins i would marrieth her into my zarina
to standeth by my side
i don't know what that means but some
people will barbara lindsay says queen
consort the queen gave her blessing
camilla has been a good supportive
daughter-in-law for the queen unlike
the previous one you mean
and wife for charles
unlike the previous one you mean william
catherine and family seem very fond of
her my goodness barbara you know a lot
uh we're all supposed to learn from
history can we stop looking for
something to
grumble about
the problem with that barbara is i was
sitting in parliament
when
a promise was made
to parliament and people
that camilla would not
become queen
yeah you remember at the time of the
divorce
the promises mean
nothing anymore
and if camilla can become queen why
what happened to mrs simpson
poor mrs simpson
they all got drummed out of the brownies
because
she was a mrs simpson as camilla was a
mrs parker-bowles
both married both committing adultery
with each other on royal premises at
your expense barbara
what about peter townsend
princess margaret had a life of misery
because she was not allowed to marry
group captain peter
townsend that's all i'm saying look
i don't actually care all that much
because i'm against
the whole thing
but barbara you're clearly fully into it
do you not care
about the contradictions
in all of that
john miles says i'm more worried about
charles being king than camilla being
queen i know it won't can't happen but
for the sake of the monarchy it would be
better to skip a generation
and flag of united kingdom pickup truck
says yes
diana is dead
people need to get over it
really paul hodder says rather have a
pearly queen
and minky pinky says no one should be
queen unless it's freddie mercury god
dressed him more says from an irish
point of view yes why not sure they have
a lot worse than camilla parker bowles
royals have a closet full of scandal
and david short says why is the pole
asking us peasants whether the queen has
made the right choice or not a who cares
b she's already made her mind up or c
get someone else to create these polls
well i suppose it matters because
she'll be our queen
she'll be the queen of our country
and uh dan fergus says the royals
however inept they are are better for
britain than the corrupt vermin in the
chambers and there are corporate
overlords
no corruption in the royal family of
course never has been
never never has been
at least the royals are tied to britain
you
you're having a laugh right
you know their name right
yeah you you know they're all german
right
you know it's saks kobar kobargota is
their name right at least they're tied
to britain
what's wrong with you dan
are you a child are you like 14
at least the royals are tied to britain
and wouldn't like to rule over a dump
well they actually do rule over a dump
while the psychos in the businesses that
own the houses
don't mind
dan i wish you'd call me
08081-965522 come and have a go if you
think you're hard enough no
i was first caught
by the fantastic name as a lifelong fan
and brief friend of the lay and lamented
prince the king of all he surveyed by
the name of a welsh band from martha
called paisley park but cleverly spelled
with a sea
they were brought to my attention by a
very good friend of mine
the owner of hamilton academicals
football club in scotland the thinking
man and woman's club as i like to call
them
because
in his spare time
in fact for most of his time
colin mcgowan
is working
for a charity called blameless you'll
know i've been involved in them now for
quite some time
they work to help the
blameless children
of drug addicts and alcoholics
you couldn't get a more blameless
and yet
harrowingly
disturbed
and troubled
section of our community than little
children whose parents
are addicted to
drugs and alcohol colin mcgowan put me
on to paisley park i went on to youtube
you'll have to do the same because for
copyright reasons we can't play their
music
and i found them to be
absolutely
astounding
i cannot believe that this band paisley
park
will not be
one of the biggest things in rock and
roll and very very soon indeed
and so the opportunity to
interview their manager gary griffiths
manager of the band paisley park
was too good to pass
and gary's with me now i hope
i think the band might be there but we
yes they are
how fantastic to see george who are you
is everybody called griffiths and mouth
or tidwell it seems i i think i i know
about a dozen griffiths in martha
tidwell
gary thanks for joining us
hey george you would i know what you
were doing with horizon a few years ago
i was i've spoken at martha rising more
than once and i've spoken actually many
times in martha i really love it i love
south wales and i'm not surprised given
the
life
that people in south wales have had to
live
with economic disaster
uh with with disasters like abervan and
so on the death of uh traditional
industry the
deindustrialization of the valleys
that this
wonderful band of yours has emerged
singing
about real things about real life tell
us about them will you
i i will say i will and to be honest to
you i think one thing i'd like to say
about martha tedville as as taffle as
roughly as it's been for all of us
especially these young kids
uh and it's their learning about what
we've done you know and how they've
grown up um
you know it's also a wonderful town it's
a wonderful town of opportune and it's
it's a it's a place that's got lots of
character as you know total character
the people are absolutely wonderful
absolutely
what i mean is they've been they've been
betrayed
by the politicians and by the system
and it has produced this wonderful band
crying out
for justice
i know and and and the guys the guys
they wrote their own song
they've written many songs as you know
judge but uh this one song that they've
written uh most recently called mean
streets and it is about mean streets
it's about growing up and unfortunately
our lead singer can't be with us tonight
he's tested positive actually but he
wanted me to
tell you the story of his feelings when
he wrote it it was about growing up and
he was young and he and he got slightly
intimidated by the whole sort of you
know how a young person can go out to
very very quickly the the situation can
change because of drinking because of
alcoholism and because of you know the
drug related stuff and when i met colin
and let's be honest colin who's the
founder of blindness they do some
fantastic work up there in hamilton i i
got i got to say this
um
george when i played in the tractor
these guys have written and and recorded
there was a tear in his eye he was
absolutely and it was a such a
connection between because it's not just
about murder it's about every city every
town in this country these young kids
they grow up
and you know what what they know what
these guys have done
is they they turn to their music they
change their guitars they turn to their
keyboards and their drums and uh and i'm
they're gonna take this rule by storm
well i i just think that i mean i played
that track and then i went looking for
others i'm sure the audience will do so
after the show uh also
i i i was knocked out by i didn't bring
a tear to my eye don't cry much but it
really did rock me back on my
heels the sheer
power of it the working-class power of
it
yeah yeah and and there's so many other
songs like that as well but
through calling as well you know
i'd like to mention that um you know
we're lucky saint luke's are there
they're hosting us on the fourth of
march and then we're going to
to the um the hamilton arches uh stadium
on the fifth of march and we've got some
gigs going up and all the proceeds these
guys are not going to take a penny it's
all going back into the blameless um
you know oh that's fantastic that's
which is great and you know it's been
it's been lovely so i'm going to jump
over a minute uh george if you can ask
the guys something about themselves i
think that yeah
we've not got a lot of time just what
pick one of who's the most eloquent i
know all welsh people are eloquent
who's going to speak
i'll speak okay brother go ahead tell us
um
well it's uh started off first as a four
it was yayan and the singer jack they
were best friends growing up
and they yayan taught jack to play
guitar and naturally they kept playing
and playing and then after a few years
they wanted to form a band
they knew jack through uh martial arts
which they went to they asked jack to be
the drummer and it was actually me and
the singer we were in a party he's good
friends with my sister and it was me and
then we stayed up playing guitar and
then that's how i performed in the band
and then do them covered
um
it gave us a good chance to
stop gigging
and actually write songs and try and
expand our sound and then we get invited
morgan down to a couple of practices and
he come with his uh keyboard and last
lady uh enhanced the sound and filled it
out
yeah
it's
you look you all look very young what
what kind of ages are the band
i'm 25.
you're the old you're the old man of the
band i think
who's the youngest
i'm a baby i'm 20 years old
20 years old well i'll tell you what
lads i know a thing or two about music
i'm a sax player former double bass
player uh and uh i've been listening to
music a long time i predict a very big
future for paisley park very smart name
by the way very smart name who picked it
very clever name lads thanks for joining
us sorry the line was not that great but
you got your message across and everyone
after this show is over please go on to
youtube and check them out i tell you
this you'll be very very impressed
coming up in the next hour the english
man of letters peter auburn
on the war in yemen and we're taking
your calls on queen camilla and more
stay tuned it's the news with jamie lowe
[Music]
radio sputnik news
her majesty the queen has become the
first british monarch to celebrate a
platinum jubilee marking 70 years on the
throne elizabeth ii's reign began when
she was just 25 years old following the
death of her father king george vi on
the 6th of february 1952.
her majesty said that she remembers
today as much for the death of her
father as for the start of her reign
this jubilee is the 95 year old molex
first without her husband the duke of
edinburgh who died last year
on the eve of her jubilee her majesty
announced her wishes for camilla duchess
of cornwall to be known as queen consort
when prince charles becomes king
prince charles welcomed his mother's
royal seal of approval of camilla saying
the pair were deeply conscious of the
honor
the usual precedent would have been for
camilla to automatically become queen
when charles was king but because of
uncertainty about public opinion it had
been suggested that that might not be
the case
in a statement prince charles commended
her majesty's devotion to the welfare of
all her people which he said inspires
still greater admiration with each
passing year
business secretary kwazii kwateng has
defended prime minister boris johnson's
use of a jimmy savile slur against sakia
stammer as perfectly reasonable asked if
he would have used the same words in the
comments kwateng highlighted that zakir
had apologized for the public
prosecution services failure to
prosecute savile
johnson appeared to distance himself
from his use of the discredited claim
after days of criticism saying that
sakia had nothing to do personally with
those decisions adding that he was
making a point about his responsibility
for the organization as a whole the
prime minister said quasi quarten has
spent the morning defending more of the
prime minister's claims to journalists
the business secretary has been accused
of being disrespectful to victims of
scammers after he defended boris
johnson's claim that crime was falling
by fourteen percent which is only true
if fraud is excluded
speaking to the bbc quasi quieting
backed boris johnson's use of the
figures saying the prime minister had
been talking about crime that people
experience in their day-to-day lives
which he said in terms of burglary in
terms of physical injury has gone down
last week the statistics watchdog took
johnson to task for making the claim as
he had not made clear that this excludes
fraud and computer misuse
including those crime has in fact
increased by 14
between the year ending september 2019
and the year ending september 2021
british serial killer levi bellfield has
confessed to the murders of mother and
daughter lynn and megan russell belfield
is serving a whole life sentence for
murdering millie dowler french student
emily de la grange and 19 year old
marsha mcdonald
michael stone was twice convicted of
murdering the russells and is serving
three life sentences in prison he's
always denied his involvement
lynn russell and her daughter megan were
found bludgeoned to death in
chillingdoon in kent in july 1996 stone
solicitor said he has received what he
called a genuine four-page statement
from belfield in which he details his
involvement in the killings kent police
however said its position on stone
conviction remains unchanged
the duke of york will give evidence
under oath next month as part of the
ongoing civil sexual assault case
against him virginia q3 is suing prince
andrew in the u.s and alleges the duke
sexually assaulted her on three
occasions when she was 17 and being
trafficked by the late financier jeffrey
epstein the duke has repeatedly denied
all allegations he will face a
deposition which will be in london on
the 10th of march and he is likely to
face many personal questions miss you
free says the duke abused her in several
locations including glen maxwell's home
in london prince anu continues to deny
the allegations and his lawyers have
said he is ready to go before a jury and
fight the claim he is not facing any
legal action in the uk
a u.s military plane touched down in an
airport in south eastern poland on
sunday the boeing c-17a globemaster 3
could be seen landing amid escalating
tensions between russia and ukraine
soldiers already landed in the western
german city of weisbaden on friday
at least 2 000 soldiers have been sent
to europe from the u.s to provide
support for nato after russia dispatched
military equipment and a reported 125
000 troops to the border of ukraine
moscow has denied any intention to
invade ukraine but has demanded a ban on
ukraine entering nato as well as a
withdrawal of nato troops from several
nearby countries
the body of a five-year-old boy who died
stuck in a well has been removed by
rescue workers the body of five-year-old
ryan who was stuck in a well for four
days before passing away was carried out
by rescue workers in tamarot on sunday a
large crowd gathered around the
ambulance that took away the body
dozens of rescuers were seen carrying
the body towards the ambulance drowned
out by noise from the surrounding crowd
the boy had been trapped in the 32 meter
deep well located in the northern
province of the country
a small group of protesters gathered
outside the white house in washington dc
on saturday to denounce proposals of u.s
military intervention amid rising
tensions on the ukraine border the rally
was organized by far-left groups
including ansar coalition and code pink
against u.s nato intervention to address
russia's military buildup banners read
no war with russia as speakers addressed
the rallying crowd the rally came after
washington announced it was sending
extra troops to europe to address the
crisis a stepped moscow condemned as
destructive
to the winter olympics now and new
zealand's zoy sadowsky synod has won the
country's first ever winter games gold
medal after her performance in the
women's slopestyle snowboarding on
sunday she addressed reporters on the
historic victory at a press conference
in zhang jiakao saying the gold medal
meant so much to her and she hopes she
made new zealanders proud the beijing
winter game started on february 4th and
will last until february 20th after that
the paralympic winter games will begin
on march the 4th lasting until march
13th
and finally malaysian visual arts
teacher saful bin bahram shah has become
an internet phenomenon after posting a
20-second tik-tok video of him drawing
portraits using his hands feet and mouth
the 39-year-old secondary school teacher
known as seifel takeith on tick tock
showcased his portraits of footballers
killian bappe lionel messi neymar
christian ronaldo and pop star michael
jackson in the northeastern malaysian
town of kuala kangsar barak on saturday
he amazed viewers for simultaneously
sketching five portraits of celebrities
and malaysian public figures using his
hands feet and mouth in his latest
tiktok which was posted on january 11th
shaw said his inspiration for the novel
method of drawing came from a disabled
artist who drew a portrait with her feet
his tic-tock video has gained more than
half a million views and more than 38
000 likes and that's the latest here on
sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves with george galloway
only on sputnik radio
should camilla be queen
no according to our audience so far
a yes 45
be no
you've still got time get your vote have
your say it's more than you'll get about
who the next monarch is to uh be
uh now you've got the numbers
080819655222
or if you're in the u.s and canada plus
one eight four four nine four four
double three double four
now i'd call it the forgotten war
in yemen
if anyone had ever remembered it in the
first place
it is truly astounding
that the poorest country
in the arab world one of the poorest
countries on the earth
has been laid waste
for almost a decade by the richest
country in the middle east and
possibly the richest country in the
world saudi arabia its next door
neighbor
even more extraordinary
they're doing it with weapons that we
have sold them
perhaps even more extraordinary than
that we have military officers
in the command and control center
in saudi arabia
that decides on the targeting
of the weapons that we
sold them
and indeed
i have reason to believe we have even
had special forces
inside yemen
doing the dirty work
for
the kings of arabia
you really couldn't make that up we live
in a country where
where we're supposedly against
dictatorship
but we are arming
and guiding
two brute dictatorships
in the massacre
of hundreds of thousands of people many
of them women and children of course
bombs have fallen down on weddings on
funerals on schools on hospitals
so much for the command and control
centers
not only
all
of that
but the media
in britain
has chosen
one must assume deliberately
to
entirely ignore it all
unless
you watch and read
a select few
you would not know that any of this was
even happening at all
let alone with our culpability in it
one of the very few
who has consistently tried to
raise a voice
for the
besieged beleaguered massacred people of
yemen
is one of the
finest men
on our island i call him the
man of english letters
author
journalist broadcaster peter oborn who
joins us now peter thank you for
doing so let me ask you that
last question first really
how come
broadcasters and journalists who
obviously do know what's happening there
how come they are
silent about it
it's a very important question which you
raised that george
because this is the greatest
humanitarian catastrophe
of the 21st century
with hundreds of thousands of people
dying
not just through the mis the missile
attacks the bombing attacks which you
just described so eloquently but also
through starvation through famine
uh through malnutrition um and not lack
of access to proper medicines and so on
and yet it's ignored
i have to say
i say not entirely ignored i mean there
has been uh some
important reporting from inside yemen
including from the bbc now while our
magathi has made several trips there
very important trips bringing some of
the horror but
um the fact is that britain is complicit
in this
um in particular we are what is known as
the pen holder at the united nations
security council we are the country
which guides policy at the united
nations
uh and yet uh we we keep on making these
uh statements about how we want to bring
peace to yemen well we're absolutely
absolutely obstructing it i'm afraid
yes
and that's what's being ignored if this
conflict was being
waged by
russia or
by china or by
a country that we
don't like
then it would be
you know buildings would be lit up in
the colors of yemen
there would be boycotts there would be
endless proselytizing
on the subject but none of that happens
here because
we are in the saudi arabian pocket deep
isn't that the truth
do you know i was in sana a few years
ago while the bombing was i i went at
the start of the civil war and i went
around seeing the
terrible uh places where the bombs had
happened i learned about
the double tap strikes you know they
don't they they they hit the
hospital once
and then the ambulance is rushed to the
scene and then they hit it again to kill
the
kill the people coming to the rescue as
well to multiply the effect of that
now i i i i i felt so ashamed
to talk to
one of the yemeni people he said to me
we admire britain we thought britain is
a fair country why are you doing this to
us explain why you in britain are doing
this
and i felt so ashamed
and you've got to
uh think that part of the reason is the
sale of arms to saudi arabia
which will be used i'm afraid for
purposes of killing innocent people that
will be one of the things which happens
with those with those arms
one of the remarkable things is that the
yemenis are fighting back
with the increasing
precision
and this is not
reported widely either
the uae a country
which is
prominent in
sponsoring football stadia and
uh
its excellent airline is patronized by
hundreds of thousands of british people
many british people go
for their holidays
to
the united arab emirates and yet yemeni
bombs are now landing in the united arab
emirates
uh pinpricks no doubt
but a sign of life
and a cry for help
from inside the yemen that's
extraordinary too isn't it
it's very interesting what has happened
inside the yemen the houthis
which are the
really a sort of religious tribal group
in the north
um
are fighting the war against saudi
arabia by the way let's not pretend
they're
their innocent virtuous
lot they're not they there are they are
two terrible human rights
abusers but i've seen these people they
are
really sort of almost pretty well
barefooted tribes people from the
mountains
living in and fighting in caves and yet
they are defeating
one of the most powerfully armed armies
backed by the united states by britain
uh yeah and uh they have
won and a whole series of wars against
the saudis with all of their munitions
that amazing aircraft their incredible
uh missiles and shells and cluster bombs
i'm afraid to say
uh we just get landed i picked one of
them up actually in a village you know
they're
killed a small child of the uh you know
and
it's um
it is very remarkable the the way in
which the hooties are fought back now
why they why were they going after uae
uae had said it's going getting out of
all kinds of this is one of these
horrible wars a proxy war with all kinds
of powers involved the uae had got out
but then they got back involved again
and this was just a sort of warning to
the uae that uh if they really want to
get involved they're going to have a to
pay a price and of course the houthis
have been sending um it's it's uh um
is it drones or missiles over towards
uh saudi arabia as well it's it's
extraordinary the
it's very similar to the taliban
you see in kabul if you think what
happened there
you have one of the poor most poorest
guerrilla armies in the
people with sandals and kalashnikovs
defeating the greatest army the world
has ever known the united states
the united states army were defeated by
the taliban this ragba ragband of poorly
armed people and the houthis are doing
the same to the us and british-backed
societies
we should have known this peter
shouldn't we uh
i'm old enough you're just about old
enough to remember
that the aidan was a colony of ours and
we were driven out of it
one of my earliest memories
becoming active in politics was
the british army uh
shooting down
arabs in the crater district
of aidan
struggling to hold on to
a colony that could not be held
we ought to have known that the
yemenis
are fighting people
that is harold wilson made the decision
in 1967 i think it was 66
to
get get out of east of surreys as they
called it i think yeah
and so that was part of that uh policy
that we've written that whether we were
defeated i don't i don't know my history
isn't
good enough but harold wilson
one of the great very underestimated
labour prime minister i think
uh he made that decision to pull british
forces out
so what happens next uh peter are we are
you and i going to grow old still
talking
about the war in yemen or is anyone
going to try and bring it to an end
well you get these very bland
meaningless statements
from the british uh foreign office
james cleverley who really ought to be
ashamed of himself the middle east
minister makes these statements about
pulling about bringing peace
joe biden i expected better of him i
thought he was going to
end u.s involvement look what we need to
see here george and it's we're both
uncomfortable i'm in a comfortable room
at my parents house at the moment you're
in a comfortable studio there are people
dying as we speak there are people being
bombed as we speak so the first thing i
do believe we need to have a united
nations resolution saying all outside
parties should get out
of the yemen that it may that includes
of course the united states
and our involvement the saudis and our
their involvement britain and our
involvement and also iran which has been
reportedly supporting the houses out
uae which has paid got a bloody nose
because it's been getting involved
recently out and i'm afraid just let the
the yemenis uh sort this out uh there
are remarkable people i i they have a
huge place in my heart these are brave
people who've had to deal with outsiders
without
foreigners who don't have good
intentions for millennia and i do hope
uh and that is what we should we now
need is everybody out of the yemen let
them sort it out themselves even that
won't be that peaceful but i
at the moment we are fueling we britain
has a horrible role shameful role along
with other countries
in allowing this conflict to go on
peter obama as always thank you for your
wisdom and for your time
this evening
in this week in 1939
which european government fled to france
a portugal b belgium
sees spain
answer after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
gosh darn how do you get this thing to
work
ah
did that one is it is it this one here
gosh
was this thing built in america jeez
kamala
would you get in here
i can't get the uh gosh darn wireless to
work
you know i can't answer questions joe
when i'm laughing
i'm trying to uh
listen to that scottish guy on the
wireless the uh
the the galloway fella oh joe you're so
funny
[Music]
i've been pressing this red button on
and off and on and off
heck i can't get it to work
uh hello biden residents
mr president be advised we have executed
the airstrike on syria
that's just great uh how long until it
gets delivered i'm starving
[Music]
sputnik has been launched to give you a
closer look at everything happening in
the world
radio sputnik
telling the untold
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends contributors and
callers everyone is welcome
the answer is spain its government fled
to france in this week in 1939
spanish prime minister juan negrin fled
to paris franco claimed victory when the
spanish civil war defense officially
ended a month later the poll should
camilla be queen
it's uh tremendous response thousands of
you have voted
but i'm sorry to
tell the palace uh that the
numbers who think that camilla should be
queen
are
not high it's still on twitter 45 yes 55
no but on youtube
it is 25 yes
75 no and on telegram it's even worse
for the palace
24 yes 76
no
truly extraordinary results i must tell
you i wasn't expecting
that
let's take some calls
rose in philadelphia is always a delight
rose
welcome back to the show
hi mr gallery i'm so happy to be back
and i'm glad to be getting on earlier in
the show than i usually do so i hope i
do it justice um okay a few points i'd
like to talk about today uh when it
comes to the beijing olympics i've been
watching it i and my family beautiful
show and of course done as safely as
possible as the chinese have been
absolutely excellent in their battle
against the pandemic
the so-called uh boycott on the basis of
human rights abuses uh particularly for
the mistreatment of the uighur muslims
yeah the west is very big on muslims of
course
in fact they don't like muslims they
don't like uh communists uh but they
they're absolutely in love with the
chinese muslims only the chinese muslims
don't love them back
not at all and neither do the muslims
here because i would like to say
something
there is only one
camp in the world that's
um torturing muslims it's called
guantanamo bay
it's right here run by the us government
on sovereign cuban soil
that's true but we're also massacring
muslims in yemen
it's our weapons
our weapons our
uh command and control uh we we're we're
up to our neck in blood of muslims in
iraq in afghanistan in libya in syria in
palestine we're up to our neck in it
but we really really care about
chinese muslims come on
i don't believe that for one second and
uh what one of the reasons that it's
been uh possible for the u.s to kill
muslims in such
big numbers and such huge scale is the
collaborators with the so-called muslims
those dictators in the gulf one of whom
qatar was just made a non-nato ally this
past week well colombia is an ally why
not qatar
oh no no problem there no problem at all
of course um and i'd also love to pay
tribute on on a lighter note to our
beloved venezuela february 4th this past
friday was their national day of dignity
that commemorates um the first time uh
commandant hugo chavez tried to
overthrow that neo-liberal cruel
president perez in 1992 although he
failed
it was just the beginning
of the dubarian revolution may god watch
over him always uh president chavez we
my wife and i were present in his last
and
as always victorious election campaign
uh and uh he's a very great loss indeed
rose thanks for that call from
philadelphia uh now news from the
podcast uh this week after a rise
another rise of 10
in our listenership last week
we have new subscribers in the
seychelles
macau
brunei
and sri lanka which means we now have
subscribers in
125 countries i'm determined that we get
to the whole the full monty
195 countries please someone identify
for me which countries we don't have
subscribers in and i'll try and drive
that and remember as i said earlier part
one of our maxwell the monster podcast
series will be released on all our
podcast platforms after next week's show
sunday the 13th of february if you
aren't listening to this
growing
podcast sensation then please subscribe
wherever you get your podcast from so
you can listen to moats anywhere it's
the distilled version shorn of all
peripheral mata
it's 98 minutes instead of three hours
you can listen to it anyway anywhere
anytime on any corner of the earth don't
forget to share with your friends and
leave us please a five star review if
you will let's go to eve in idaho on the
subject of north korea go ahead eve
hello george thank you for
having me on on your beautiful show
thank you yes you know
a few weeks ago i realized something and
i wanted to share it with you and to
know what you think
you remember
two or three years ago we had the trump
uh trying to make peace in north korea
and it was
shut down
and
people say oh it's because of john
bolton but
john bolton had no power really was an
advisor he was not
so that's one fact and the second fact
is
that we have seen recently
many hypersonic
weapon of some kind being launched
by north korea
and america
doesn't seem to care at all
and then i came to the ballistic
missile i mean the next stage is one
that can land in san francisco you think
they'd be concerned
yes but they didn't you
as you have observed
we didn't make a big fuss no compared to
we make in ukraine or taiwan
and
and the reason i think is
i came to the following observation
is that the deep state
told trump
and
that north korea is no threat for united
states but it's the reason why
we are allowed to have nuclear weapon in
south korea which is a fantastic
geostrategic position
and so the uh if there would be a peace
between south and north korea
it will be probably a neutral country or
something like that and that's not what
we want we want to have those weapons in
south korea very probably targeted to
russia and china and north korea is just
a good reason to have them there
that was my observation
well let's say it's a kanye
observation uh it's betting on the
somewhat unpredictable nature of the
uh leadership in north korea not
actually using or
meaningfully threatening to use their
growing
now ballistic
nuclear capability it's quite a bet it's
quite a potential
price to pay eve so although your
hypothesis
is credible
plausible
um
it's not very wise in my view uh
engagement with north korea by trump
was a good idea
uh and should have been supported
rather than ridiculed
and might have led to fruition after all
north korea just wants to
live and follow its own
somewhat idiosyncratic course
well yes but if you look at at the
policy of of the united states is
basically to put
like we said last week is to put nuclear
weapons yeah in strategic area on the
earth although they've got them in japan
which isn't far away but i take your
point south korea is a useful launch pad
but if lost then japan will always be
a reliable u.s launch pad
well yeah to a certain uh to to a
certain extent i mean you know they have
a lot to lose the japanese are very
close to china
um
they they may want to have their own
nuclear weapon at some point i mean
yeah what could possibly go wrong
thanks very much eve uh should camilla
be queen uh yes a
b no please get your vote in before that
poll closes
anonymous is on the line in the uk wants
to be called anonymous i don't know why
but he wants to talk about the economy
mr mrs miss
anonymous welcome
uh thanks for taking my call george the
reason why i want to say anonymous is
that i work for an amazing polling
company in the uk and i don't want to
okay so against my terms
no that's fine that's fine yeah so so i
speak to the british population on a
day-to-day basis uh quite a lot and and
we pull for opinions from the young to
the old uh and i'd like to share with
you george my my experience as working
in that job um across those
demographics
and what what's what i found amazing is
the older population are really quite
upbeat quite resilient and they've led
they've led fruitful lives now
they've not
they've not lived through the world war
ii but they've actually been youngsters
during that period and then probably
the main time was during the macmillan
macmillan you've never had it so good
years does that make sense to you yes
yes indeed
and and what i'm finding is when i'm
pulling the younger demographic which
we're struggling to get the opinions of
is that i actually believe that they are
going through a war wall-like scenario
right now in terms of
pdsd in terms of
uh not being able to go to work not be
able to meet people not being have
relationships
cover have wear masks and i'm seeing a
real significant
result from that
well that's troubling isn't it
it is very troubling because i mean one
of my one of my recent polls was to
businesses about their opinions on
different things and and i'm calling so
many people it's heartbreaking george
because most of them have closed down
not had business
desperate
and i'm not going to swear because i get
a lot of that and my
on my polls because
that's how desperate people are you know
and the worst is yet to come of course
uh we are uh we're going to be
by most accounts uh back to 2008 just
around the corner we already know
there's uh
massive rises in
in energy costs already now uh
unavoidable
and there's the increase in national
insurance there are
closures
just down the line there's the bank of
england
chairman on half a million a year
saying that people should not be having
a wage increase even though he's
predicting an inflation rate of seven
percent
uh by the middle of this year in other
words a
very significant drop in people's living
standards just around the corner
it is devastating it breaks my heart
when i speak to these people um george
have you um i i i i watched today and i
mentioned on the channel but neil or
neil oliver from uh gb news he had a
great piece today about
um the the impact on the youngsters the
impact on
you know uh
did have you do you know neil oliver uh
well i i've not actually met him but we
are a good friends uh by text
i i admire him very much
uh can i just
and like his you know your audience i
don't want to distract from your channel
because i listen to you every day my my
weekly updates georgetown thank you for
that
um one one thing i'd like to say to
george which i'm slightly disappointed
is is that you've not mentioned that the
truckers freedom convoy is being
defunded by gofundme and and i think
that's one of the most important it's uh
very significant
i did actually major on that issue last
sunday
but not the defunding uh because that
hadn't happened then i just ran out of
time basically uh but it's one of the
most egregious acts
uh of state directed theft
uh that i have ever seen in my entire
life just to explain uh to the
audience
uh
nine million dollars
was donated freely by
the public in canada in the united
states indeed all over the world
to the canadian truckers
who
whose heroic
exploits i talked about at length last
week
through
a platform called go fund me
gofundme has taken the political
decision
to seize that money
and not to pass on to the truckers
even worse
in an act brazen act of theft
they initially said
that they would not be returning it to
the donors
that they would decide which good causes
this nine million dollar theft would be
donated to
the backlash has been very considerable
and they've backed down from that and
they are now automatically
uh
returning to the donors nine million
dollars but the important thing is they
have
stopped it going where the donors wanted
it to go
last one to you sir
just like check out diva frey he's a
canadian youtuber who has recently
interviewed the counter protest
and
he was he he got shortchanged because
black lives matter who are currently
funded by gofundme
shut him down
uh well in fact black lives matters are
in tremendous uh legal difficulty and
have been
stopped from further
fundraising across many parts of the
united states of our concerns
about what they've done with the many
millions
that they receive from corporate and
individual donors thanks for giving me
the prod to
bring that up i appreciate it let's talk
to sarkar in glasgow go ahead sarkar
long time no see uh no no george
sometimes i get busy with work but i
never miss your show thank you george
really nice to see you keep her healthy
thank you small question george and
that's quite a major question it's with
relations to what's happening
with russia and the war mongering by the
americans yeah now i'd like to make
something very clear over here for all
the audiences i may or may not agree
with everything
vladimir putin does
but one thing i can say
when the americans start hysterically
war mongering having seen their amazing
history with what has happened in iraq
afghanistan syria libya
don't get me wrong i'm not saying putin
is the same but i definitely would count
on put in more in this scenario than a
joe biden or an american media
the problem which we have is
i don't know
why whether other americans so much
interested in getting uk also involved
in the conflict we can benefit much more
by trading with russia the germans are
trading with russia they're getting the
north stream
supply for gas and oil why can the
britons not trade we have shut down the
coal plants we are increasing the price
of our electricity
russia is happy to get their gas we
don't need to dig for our own why can we
not trade with them why do we always
have to believe that russia is some sort
of an enemy well let's see
that's the 64 000
sarkar all i can say is it was above us
we fought the russians in the
uh crimean war
uh we
invaded russia
in
1920 with
hundreds of thousands of soldiers not
many people know that
hundreds of thousands
of western soldiers
foremost amongst them then
our own soldiers
and naval forces we invaded russia
to try and regime change
the government there
we invaded it
with land forces
we then were
amongst the most bitter protagonists
of the
uh
cold war period
uh before the
brief and glorious interlude of our
wartime alliance but even during that
wartime alliance
we
betrayed
russia
then the soviet union we betrayed it
i was watching a very important
documentary world war ii in color it's
called
just the other night
the reason why
the so-called spies
philby burgess maclean blunt cairn cross
in particular
were
forced to give
our ally
the soviet union the battle plan the
battle order and crucial
uh information about armaments held
by the vermont at kursk the reason why
they had to be
secretly given to the soviet union is
because
britain held them in london and did not
pass them on
to our own ally
in a battle
which became
the decisive battle of the second world
war so
we've got form
on this
we hate
in the british state
in the institution next door to me here
in the institution across the water from
me there
in the building along the road from me
in the houses of parliament we
have always hated russia
when it was
zarist in the
time of the crimean war when it was
communist in the time of the bolsheviks
and now there is a capitalist country
under president putin we've always
hated it there's three different
political systems the one thing that is
consistent
is british hatred
towards russia why
i just don't have enough time or enough
words to explain it to you but it ain't
any kind of surprise to me sarkar
now
i've got a question
on this day in 1998
which us airport was renamed after
ronald reagan
a new york north
b washington national
see denver
airport
answer after the break
radio sputnik
[Music]
t minus 10
9 8 7
ignition
liftoff
we need to
acclimatize the public
uh for the introduction of
extraterrestrials
because
come to the conclusion at this point if
they're going to come they are going to
come soon
back in the late 60s and early 70s they
actually saw the softer land in front of
them or passed by in new york or go
overhead
they said the same line that you just
made and it was amazing it is an awful
waste of space
if if we are all
that there is exactly have you ever seen
any of these phenomena i have seen
energy entities one look like a
massive jellyfish the other one looked
like a massive centipede
well you had me up to that point now i
just think you're stark raving mad
the tough questions are the most
powerful weapon we have as long as you
have questions we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik
telling the
untold and the answer is of course
washington
national though i suppose most people
that use it
no longer know
why
is the poll still running should camilla
be queen 2 800 people have voted a few
minutes left if you've not got yours in
but it's very bad news for the palace i
know that you're watching charles
i know that a little bird told me
in that what's that boozer next to the
palace the barricades or something where
all the gossips go
uh somebody told me that you watch
it's bad news
turn back turn back there's some amazing
uh social media can i
kevin 14 says stop dissing monarchy for
goodness sake would you rather a plastic
president
well i'd rather a plastic president than
an idiot king
and i'm sorry to tell you i regard
prince charles
as close to imbecility
and i have done for many years and i say
that as someone who served the queen
who pledged allegiance to her i served
there as a wine waiter in the angus
hotel in dundee
and then has served her again as a
member of
her majesty's loyal opposition
dave says we have a head of state we
cannot elect and can't remove
we have over 700 members of the house of
lords we cannot elect and cannot remove
and in the house of commons the ruling
party only has to get 40 percent of the
vote to get full control
democracy in my backside
very very good dave i like that that's
the
message of the night and uh paul jackson
says the only queen in the royals is
edward i have no idea what that means
helen pence says there was a promise at
the time of their marriage i told you
that camilla would not be queen
the royal family has reneged on that
promise broken promises seem to be a
regular occurrence in our broken country
but mark says the queen trusts her and
charles wants her she's not put a foot
wrong but david of england says making
her queen would be the equivalent to
spitting on diana's grave
and frontique
an english antique aged to perfection
hey
that's me except i'm scottish
she may as well get the title she's done
the job kept her mouth shut unlike his
youngest son and wife hopefully she can
keep him in line
but adds i'm past caring really
jalau is in
manchester let's hear from jalal go
ahead jalal
hello george hi
um george if memory certainly correct
um bojo had to meet had a one-to-one
[Music]
well educate me i i didn't know that
10 minutes apparently there were chit
chatting um
one to one yeah and then about four
within 14 days or so it was announced
that um amazon will be getting the
contract to store
information on their cloud or whatever
the system is called
and it's going to cost about 10 billion
is it over four years or something
you're uh you're educating me here jalau
i know nothing of any of that but i'll
make it my business to find out
well we've wasted we wasted nearly 10
billion on on ppe
uh mainly
to cronies so it wouldn't surprise me
what about the what about the money
that's been wasted on the nhs uh
computer systems
legendary don't work legendary legion
it's just legion constant these people
think that's a kleptocracy we've got
not a democracy we've got a kleptocracy
true true but one of the people going to
stand up
well i've done my best for the last 50
years and more uh jalal
george it's it's the masses yeah the man
that broke these morons in and it's the
masses
trying to rouse the masses jalal that's
why i'm here
uh thanks for the call ian is in hounds
logo ahead ian
good evening george
i was gonna phone you up to talk about
some rousing music after your interview
with paisley park yeah then i saw your
heart-rending interview with peter obam
it was
it was very heart-rending yeah
now i have a sort of
tenuous link to yemen because my father
served in aden ah and series
and he grew up in the yemeni community i
don't really know the last cars up on t
side i do very well yeah to school we
went to school with them so you know
you've got sort of a tenuous link
now
i've written to my mp about this
and all she did was write a letter to
the to the foreign office
but i expected that i said to back to in
a letter i want her to phone into radio
stations i wanted to ask questions in
parliament and i wanted to write letters
in newspaper and she's done none of that
i've written letters to to newspapers
mainly the metro they're not being
published i'm phoning into lbc when they
start slagging off russia and china and
bring up the hypocrisy of yemen i'm not
getting through because i've been call
screened
right this is i've emailed every
religious group in the united kingdom
including the the westminster cathedral
the the catholic the church of england
the sikhs the jewish border deputies i
only got one reply from the salvation
army who said it's really something
they're not involved in
this is disgraceful
this is absolutely disgraceful now do
you remember boris's stupid little stunt
outside the russian embassy with the
with the legs about half a dozen idiots
with dummy legs over the syrian civil
war and russia's involvement to try and
stop it being taken over by islamists
well i want to see thousands of people
outside the saudi arabian embassy with
seven heads from mannequins because they
are the biggest head choppers in the
world and
dead um sort of dummies dummy dollies
uh baby dollies spread everywhere
because of the signify the children
they've murdered in yemen
if boris can do it we can do it but it
means numbers it means numbers
well you've rather made my point
about the extent to which the political
class and their media echo chamber are
purposefully it's not that they don't
know about it they know as much as uri
uh ian uh it's that they are
purposefully uh turning a nelson's eye
to
what peter called the worst humanitarian
catastrophe of the 21st century and
there's quite a few competing contenders
for that ian thanks for the call michael
is in minneapolis welcome back michael
hey george good to be on good man
it's uh it has been quite a week in
propaganda here in the united states
i'll tell you what it's been one for the
ages in my opinion so
starting out uh
state department spokesperson ned price
on thursday
claimed that russia is going to stage a
fake attack
in order to embolden support for a war
with the ukraine
a journalist pushed back and said what
is this evidence
and he said i just told you the evidence
and when pressed further
said that he could print off
uh the the transcript of the press
conference as evidence and the reporter
said no you need to show us some
evidence it reminded me of a time when
there was a trade called journalism
michael he was from the associated press
we should uh give them a heart tip for
that yeah it reminded me
of a time when every question at a press
conference would be a question like that
yeah i mean you're absolutely right and
he also seemed was completely you know
this ned price was completely indignant
and said you know i'm sorry you don't
trust the intelligence committee as if
they didn't lie about weapons of mass
destruction exactly exactly well he went
further he said you can
you can be a mouthpiece for the russians
if you like all he asked was can you
show me any evidence of what you've just
claimed
absolutely and i'll tell you what george
i thought that was going to be the high
point in propaganda for the week and
then i watched the olympic opening
ceremonies and that was crazy i mean
they brought on in america they brought
they spent half an hour before even
showing the ceremonies they brought on
four different uh so-called china
experts from academia from journalism to
talk about you know the uyghur genocide
how awful it was you know how terrible
the chinese are how they shouldn't be
hosting the olympic games at all and i'm
just thinking man i don't ever remember
this kind of coverage before the last
time china hosted the olympics or before
russia hosted the olympics or before or
when canada hosted the olympics but why
this time this year
it's hysteria michael it's his criteria
look thanks for your call i've got to go
to canada forgive me tom is in vancouver
on the on the truckers go ahead tom
hi george i'm a retired truck driver
welcome
to junior
and um
i'd like to tell you a few things first
of all there's over 300 000 truck
drivers in canada
uh the teamsters union have about a
third of those membership
the teamsters union have not adored
endorsed this campaign by
these uh renegade truck drivers who are
fighting they covet
the fighting state mandates
they're fighting they're wanting to be
able to cross the border without having
to get a vaccine americans won't let
them in without a vaccine the canadians
won't let them back in again without a
vaccine they can't get across the border
without a vaccine
no the the the the canadian government
issued a pronunciation
that mandated truck drivers to get
vaccinated
and
thousands of trucks hold on thousands of
truckers told them to go and do one
i'm with the truckers are you you're
wrong you're wrong the the mandate was
only if you were crossing the border i
want to get back into canada you can
drive anywhere within canada without
having to take a vaccine you're dead
long check your facts i've already
checked my facts i'm well aware of my
facts but let me ask you this tom
how come
thousands
of your fellow truckers
have taken to the highway
in this protest
yeah well out of 320 odd thousand
drivers in canada they are a small small
tiny doesn't look very small small tiny
minority to me tom and i've seen the
pictures
well yes
you may have but there's still only a
small minority no it doesn't look like a
small small tiny minority let me ask you
one last question because we're almost
out of time
are you do you believe as
the canadian broadcasting corporation
does
that the russians were behind the
trucker's protest
i'm a lefty here okay i'm a socialist
yeah do you believe do you believe that
the russians were behind
that's not why i asked you do are you
like cbc
of the mind that the russians organized
this
of course not
excellent of course not at least we
found at least we found
tom in vancouver alas
i've got to break for the news coming up
after the news we're live to washington
to speak to artie america's rachel
blevins and do call in if you're in
canada on the trucker's story uh but by
the way have we not got tom mcgregor
from china
he's coming up later too he was at the
olympic games opening i think we'll want
to hear from him an american in beijing
don't you think the poll is closed
should camilla be queen 3
000 people voted
and i'm sorry chuck
it's yes 45 believe that camilla should
be queen
but 55 percent
believe that she should not so you might
want to
put that in your pipe and smoke it not
that you would do anything
as
20th century uh smoking but here is the
next poll are you
boycotting the beijing 2022
winter olympics
after the news with jamie lowe
[Music]
so
radio sputnik news
her majesty the queen has become the
first british monarch to celebrate a
platinum jubilee marking 70 years on the
throne elizabeth ii's reign began when
she was just 25 years old following the
death of her father king george vi on
the 6th of february 1952
her majesty said that she remembers
today as much for the death of her
father as for the start of her reign
this jubilee is the 95 year old
monarch's first without her husband the
duke of edinburgh who died last year
on the eve of her jubilee her majesty
announced her wishes for camilla duchess
of cornwall to be known as queen consort
when prince charles becomes king
prince charles welcomed his mother's
royal seal of approval of camilla saying
the pair were deeply conscious of the
honor
the usual precedent would have been for
camilla to automatically become queen
when charles was king but because of
uncertainty about public opinion it had
been suggested that that might not be
the case
in a statement prince charles commended
her majesty's devotion to the welfare of
all her people which he said inspires
still greater admiration with each
passing year
business secretary quasi quartering has
defended prime minister boris johnson's
use of a jimmy savile slur against sakia
stamina as perfectly reasonable asked if
he would have used the same words in the
comments quartering highlighted that
zakir had apologized for the public
prosecution services failure to
prosecute savile johnson appeared to
distance himself from his use of the
discredited claim after days of
criticism saying that sakia had nothing
to do personally with those decisions
adding that he was making a point about
his responsibility for the organization
as a whole the prime minister said quasi
quarten has spent the morning defending
more of the prime minister's claims to
journalists
the business secretary has been accused
of being disrespectful to victims of
scammers after he defended boris
johnson's claim that crime was falling
by 14
which is only true if fraud is excluded
speaking to the bbc quasi quoting backed
boris johnson's use of the figures
saying the prime minister had been
talking about crime that people
experience in their day-to-day lives
which he said in terms of burglary in
terms of physical injury has gone down
last week the statistics watchdog took
johnson to task for making the claim as
he had not made clear that this excludes
fraud and computer misuse
including those crime has in fact
increased by 14 percent between the year
ending september 2019 and the year
ending september 2021
british serial killer levi belfield has
confessed to the murders of mother and
daughter lynn and megan russell belfield
is serving a whole life sentence for
murdering millie dowler french student
emily de la grange and 19 year old
marsha mcdonald
michael stone was twice convicted of
murdering the russells and is serving
three life sentences in prison he's
always denied his involvement
lynn russell and her daughter megan were
found bludgeoned to death in chilendon
in kent in july 1996 stone solicitor
said he has received what he called a
genuine four-page statement from
belfield in which he details his
involvement in the killings kent police
however said its position on stone
conviction remains unchanged
the duke of york will give evidence
under oath next month as part of the
ongoing civil sexual assault case
against him virginia q3 is suing prince
andrew in the u.s and alleges the duke
sexually assaulted her on three
occasions when she was 17 and being
trafficked by the late financier jeffrey
epstein the duke has repeatedly denied
all allegations he will face a
deposition which will be in london on
the 10th of march and he is likely to
face many personal questions ms q3 says
the duke abused her in several locations
including glen maxwell's home in london
prince anu continues to deny the
allegations and his lawyers have said he
is ready to go before a jury and fight
the claim he is not facing any legal
action in the uk
a u.s military plane touched down in an
airport in southeastern poland on sunday
the boeing c-17a globemaster 3 could be
seen landing amid escalating tensions
between russia and ukraine
soldiers already landed in the western
german city of weisbaden on friday
at least 2 000 soldiers have been sent
to europe from the us to provide support
for nato after russia dispatched
military equipment and a reported 125
000 troops to the border of ukraine
moscow has denied any intention to
invade ukraine but has demanded a ban on
ukraine entering nato as well as a
withdrawal of nato troops from several
nearby countries
the body of a five-year-old boy who died
stuck in a well has been removed by
rescue workers the body of five-year-old
ryan who was stuck in a well for four
days before passing away was carried out
by rescue workers in tamarot on sunday a
large crowd gathered around the
ambulance that took away the body
dozens of rescuers were seen carrying
the body towards the ambulance drowned
out by noise from the surrounding crowd
the boy had been trapped in the 32 metre
deep well located in the northern
province of the country
a small group of protesters gathered
outside the white house in washington dc
on saturday to denounce proposals of u.s
military intervention amid rising
tensions on the ukraine border the rally
was organized by far left groups
including answer coalition and code pink
against u.s nato intervention to address
russia's military buildup banus read no
war with russia as speakers addressed
the rallying crowd the rally came after
washington announced it was sending
extra troops to europe to address the
crisis a step moscow condemned as
destructive
to the winter olympics now and new
zealand's zoy sadowsky synod has won the
country's first ever winter games gold
medal after her performance in the
women's slopestyle snowboarding on
sunday she addressed reporters on the
historic victory at a press conference
in zhang jiakao saying the gold medal
meant so much to her and she hopes she
made new zealanders proud the beijing
winter game started on february 4th and
will last until february 20th after that
the paralympic winter games will begin
on march the 4th lasting until march
13th
and finally malaysian visual arts
teacher saful bin bahram shah has become
an internet phenomenon after posting a
20-second tick-tock video of him drawing
portraits using his hands feet and mouth
the 39 year old secondary school teacher
known as seifel taketh on tick tock
showcased his portraits of footballers
killian bappe lionel messi neymar
christian ronaldo and pop star michael
jackson in the northeastern malaysian
town of kuala kangsar barak on saturday
he amazed viewers for simultaneously
sketching five portraits of celebrities
and malaysian public figures using his
hands feet and mouth in his latest tick
tock which was posted on january 11th
shaw said his inspiration for the novel
method of drawing came from a disabled
artist who drew a portrait with her feet
his tick tock video had gained more than
half a million views and more than 38
000 likes and that's the latest here on
sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves with george galloway
on sputnik radio
well this is the poll that will separate
the sheep sheep from the goats are you
boycotting the beijing 2022 winter
olympics
and the answer so far is a yes 44
be no 56
although on youtube it's yes 25
no
75 percent and on telegram
it's yes 30
no
so you can get your vote in on my
twitter account on my youtube channel on
my telegram channel it is astounding to
me as i said in my opening remarks
there's so many people
that regard the media as
inveterate
and complete liars
people who believe that they're lying
about
boris johnson the lying about kierstarma
they're lying about
jeremy corbyn they're lying about donald
trump the lying about joe biden
they were lying about iraq
are somehow telling the truth about
china what's wrong with you people
let's see if it's the same in the united
states
where my distinguished colleague and
a name that you should
put in
your mind because you'll be hearing much
more of her it's rachel blevins who
joins me from the usa uh let's start
with the
uh with the um
chinese chinese olympic story rachel
because
i saw i know i was probably the only
person in the world to see it because
nobody watches it anymore
i saw cnn
almost give over their entire
channel
to anti-china propaganda
and yet still
17 million people watched an opening
ceremony
that took the breath away
17 million americans i mean
what's the real
view in america about this
you know it's interesting because of
course when you mention cnn at the
moment they're just trying to get people
to watch their channel because their
viewership is down over 77 over the last
year
now when it comes to the overwhelming
majority of americans you know i think
we're in this place where we've had 20
years of this ongoing war on terrorism
we get to the end of that as the united
states decides it and then now they've
decided that the two new targets are
going to be china and russia and so you
have a number of people who look at this
you know new decided bad guy as it comes
from the us establishment and they may
have concern about that in one way or
another but then you have the people who
just become completely they get to the
point where it's like they've heard so
much of this they've heard so much of
sort of the boy who cried wolf when it
comes to the media and whoever their bad
guy is at the moment that they
completely tune it out and they don't
pay attention to the consequences of all
of that warmongering they don't pay
attention to what happens when the
united states continues to ramp up its
military involvement around the world
when it continues to you know carry out
these freedom of navigation exercises as
it refers to them right around china and
right around russia and they don't
really pay attention to it until it
becomes too late until we get ourselves
in a situation where we're now looking
at a direct military conflict
and i think that when it comes to
something like the olympics sure there
are some people who are going to boycott
it and make a huge scene of it but at
the end of the day does that really do
anything for them in their daily lives i
would say no not really but boycott for
why i mean
nobody seriously believes
that the united states
gives a toss
about chinese muslims the united states
doesn't like chinese doesn't like
muslims
so why would it be in love with chinese
muslims i mean you don't have to be the
brain of america to work out something's
going on here
you know that is the question of the day
truly and i think you put it perfectly
and it comes back to the fact that the
american people especially here are
still in a place where they don't have
to see proof of something in order to
believe it and you would think that we
went through this with weapons of mass
destruction and yet now we're in a
situation where they hear any kind of
figure they hear you know a million
uyghurs and they immediately latch onto
that without ever having to see any
proof of it without ever having to
question the government that is telling
them that the media that is telling them
that and then at the same time it's like
we don't sit here and talk about the
fact that the united states is engaging
in helping saudi arabia commit a very
real genocide in yemen we don't talk
about the fact that we never get to see
the images of that we never get to see
the aftermath of what those u.s drone
strikes look like and the people that
are impacted by them and so i think it
comes back to the fact that far too many
people are desensitized by this and they
just hear something in the media and yes
as you pointed out even if they will sit
there and say all day long i don't trust
cnn i don't trust fox news in the new
york times or whatever it may be it's as
if they latch on to this new theory and
they say well i can't be the one to
question that or to ask where the actual
evidence is and why it's not being
presented right in front of me of course
most of the world is there including the
united states olympic team so they don't
feel that strongly about it or they
wouldn't be there uh the most of the
world's political leaders are there
uh the boycott is a flop
but most importantly
uh the visit to beijing by president
putin
opened a new chapter in world affairs
didn't it
it absolutely did and you know the
united states should have seen this
coming for miles which is that when you
take two major countries and you point
to them and you say hey you are both our
main targets well then that gives those
two countries incentives to then work
together and to look for different ways
that they can come together and that
they can rely less on the country that
is targeting them which in this case is
the united states and you know i know
we've been talking about everything
that's been going on in europe when it
comes to the skyrocketing energy prices
that we've seen in recent months when it
comes to the fact that germany literally
has a pipeline they just built in
connection with russia that they could
be using to help crack down on those
energy prices and yet the reason that
they're not seems to come right back to
the fact that the united states has been
warmongering and scaring them against
allowing the nordstrom 2 pipeline to go
into existence and to provide the relief
that they need in a great way so then
what happens well russia comes together
with china and they agree on a long-term
natural gas deal which this is all that
russia has been asking for from europe
is they want those long-term deals they
want to be able to give them natural gas
at the lowest possible prices but they
want to lock in those long-term deals in
order to do it and europe has said no we
don't want to do that instead you know
they want to go about ways that aren't
helpful to their people so what does
that do for russia well then they go
over to china and china becomes the
customer and it makes the united states
look absolutely ridiculous because not
only does it harm
europe in the process it also puts the
us in a situation where these two bad
guys it claims it has created are now
working together to become even more
powerful than before brilliantly put
lastly rachel it's a busy night uh
how's joe
the last time i saw him he wasn't
looking that great
you know he doesn't seem to be doing
that great and i think that you know we
we talked about how they don't really
want him to give press conferences
anymore how he's tried to stay away from
that well this week his administration
looked absolutely ridiculous in the
press conferences they did give in which
we had state department spokesperson ned
price sitting there refusing to answer
the most basic questions about why the
united states continues to claim that
russia is about to invade ukraine we had
press secretary john saki sitting there
and literally when she was asked about
how the united states knew how it had
proof that a reported terrorist was the
one who blew himself and his family up
in syria she literally sat there and
said either you believe the united
states government or you believe isis so
i think that joe biden he may be staying
silent now but his administration is
certainly saying a lot and it's not
doing any of them a bit of good right
now they are in trouble on that front
because the worm eventually turns and
this was not some
you know revolutionary journalist this
was the associated press
accredited white house correspondent
who simply said
have you got you know
like
any evidence of what you've just said
and he was treated as if he was a
foreign agent
um yeah this is
might terrify some journalists but it
must have an impact on the public
credibility of what the u.s state is
saying
oh absolutely and it brings up the fact
that you know we sit here and say well
wait a second we never got proof of
weapons of mass destruction in the
united states launched an entire war
more than a million people died as a
result of it so maybe we should ask for
some proof in this case especially when
you have the binding administration
sitting there not only saying that
russia is planning some sort of false
flag but now because they have turned
into the boy who cried wolf they are
upping the ante and claiming that russia
is going to put out some sort of fake
video in order to justify an invasion of
ukraine well yeah you would think that
more people in the media would be
sitting there going wait a second where
is your proof for this how are do you
know and why are you claiming that this
is going to happen and the fact that
just one reporter was able to say that
and it made the state department look as
ridiculous as it did this week serves as
a reminder of what the media should be
doing every single day and what they
refuse to do every day
rachel blevins as always a delight to
talk with you thanks for joining us are
you boycotting the beijing olympics uh
only 600 have voted so it's not that
representative yet if you've got uh a
vote uh then cast it on my twitter
handle george galloway on my youtube
channel on my telegram channel let's go
to
fred in buxton go ahead fred
hi george nice to hear from you a long
time since i was in baxter but yeah well
i've been on a couple of times we
usually talk about man united ah yes yes
uh probably best avoided this week
yeah although the handball was a
disgrace it was it was but there should
there should have been five up by then
yeah they should yeah but anyway i've
phoned to talk to you about i know
you're keen on a conspiracy theory
so i've got i've got one for you okay
and this go rachel blevins has just
covered quite a bit of it but
yeah
we have nordstrom 2
they're ready to turn the tap on and get
signed off yeah yeah
and
all of a sudden
europe has a
energy crisis we've all got to pay
50 odd percent more in energy
the russians have got enough gas to
supply the whole world with cheap gas
yeah not now because they're going to
sell it to china but go on
well i think they probably still have a
bit left oh they do they do i'll tell
you what i mean i'll let you back in
fred if i was russia i would tell the
european market to get lost i i'd rather
leave it in the ground
than sell it to countries that are
lining up to
attack invade
uh and have a war with me i'd rather
leave it in the ground and uh
china india uh are uh
potential customers of
such magnitude that who needs to supply
gas to belgium
yeah i'm with you george
when are we going go on fred the point
is that they're ready to turn the tap on
we have this 50 hike in
gas prices yeah power prices energy
prices that'll be a lot more than 50 by
the way before it joined well yeah i
believe it's four percent in france
because they own the
energy companies but anyway i did see
that claim today i can't vouch for that
uh and it was a labour mp that was
claiming it so i've got to treat it with
a deal of
suspicion
but undoubtedly other countries that own
their energy sectors or at least are
willing to control
the profits of their energy sector
will protect their people more than our
government is going to protect us do you
know
it's slightly a digression but do you
know that shell
has just turned in
well another one billion pound profit
one billion
shell in a quarter go ahead that was
part of my conspiracy
is that they turn off the tap from
russia
and all of a sudden shell has record
profits we've all got to pay huge gas
bills
nobody's asking for a windfall tax on
shell
i am
but nobody nobody in parliament that's
right
yeah conveniently the russians
are pushed out of it and we're going to
make war with them and one other thing
concerning crimea george yeah
imagine if scotland get gets their way
and they go independent
yeah
god forbid but go on
well yeah but just an analogy for you
suppose they then say to russia
we're frightened now that we've exceeded
from the
union
we want your protection and we want you
to move your navy into fast lane
can you imagine what would happen
nightmare scenario that one fred thanks
for that call you're a clever man peter
in middlesbrough go ahead peter
good evening george i've been following
you for many years and uh i agree with
99 percent of what you say well that'll
do me peter that'll do me
i've admired you believe me but
we'll never ever mention the northern
ireland protocol and the pro the
contradictions are created by we have
we had uh somebody on it last week and
and and we had the liverpool professor
uh several times on it go ahead peter
what i don't like is everybody who
approaches brexit is labeled sort of
right wing and
and everything but you can stand you
know support uh support being in the eu
well they do now they didn't have the
time of lisbon
ah but they do now yeah yeah well
that's the player that's the
blairization of shin fein
what about all of this all i mean the
right wing of the tory party you're
going to use all of this to destroy
destroy the basic rights that we get
from the eu i mean what basic rights do
we get from the eu well uh consumer
rights the quality of food well can we
can we not have our own consumer rights
did we not have any rights before we
joined the eu
the third party you're going to use you
know well the 35 he's going to use them
to dilute them completely well would you
get the tory party out then
well that's right
why are you asking
belgium and holland and romania and
bulgaria to look after us can we look
after ourselves peter
we well we can but i mean we've been
living in modern world now you know i
mean
they're the only country between us and
the ukraine
and we're the only one that
between them that's not a member of this
i i just don't get the mentality of this
it is such a supine attitude of
helplessness hopelessness we had trade
unions that won rights for workers and
consumers and the families of those
long before we joined the eu we won
equal rights for women we won the clean
air act we won rights for people long
before we joined the eu it's so pitiful
peter that you're expecting johnny
foreigner to protect your food standards
because you don't believe the british
people are up to the job themselves
be gone with you saji is in dallas in uh
texas on the ukraine go ahead saji
oh hi george this is the saji gopal here
welcome
my opinion is the american military
industrial complex which nato is a part
of is the biggest enemy of working class
the working class in europe or working
class in united states because it sucks
up billions of billions of dollars into
this war machine right exactly
and you know responsible for you know
thousands of lives right i i think joe
biden
is playing a you know a poster boy for
this military industrial complex right
and you know they want a bloody war in
order to
you know offshore their inventories to
create a market for this weapons
industry right that is the one point and
second thing is in the geopolitical game
between united states and russia
unfortunately ukraine has become a palm
right
i think
maybe it's more sensible for ukraine to
make at peace with russia and declare
ukraine is a neutral country like a you
know like a switzerland you know some
other country right i think in order to
if they really want to save right but i
think the last point is the people of
europe right has to take action they
have to
you know
give an economic boycott of nato and
remove foreign troops from europe right
because i'll tell you what
if i won the lottery which i'd need to
start doing it if i was going to win it
if i won the lottery
i would
set up a no two nato campaign throughout
europe
throughout the continent of europe
because i believe there are
millions of people that think like you
and me that are asking themselves
why have we still got nato
the warsaw pact
is 30 years dead why have we still got
nato
and why are we bringing qatar into it
that well-known north atlantic power why
we're bringing colombia in south america
into the north atlantic treaty
organization thanks for the call brother
in dallas mike is in stock let's hear
from him
oh george i've got some good news for
you tell me uh you know the brexit
dividend we were expecting to have spent
right uh-huh it was going to be spent on
ports
ports right uh
the only problem is a jord
they're ports in ukraine
haven't they done
i thought you were going to ask me about
them
free ports across the country that's a
bit of a brexit dividend isn't it
yeah but i thought you'd be upset about
them building ports in ukraine uh well i
am and my views on uh british
involvement in ukraine are
are uh are well enough known but
i get the impression that
some people haven't just haven't quite
accepted that we've actually left the
european union mike
yeah yeah i'm i'm all for it yeah good
man but what i'm saying is that what a
waste is another waste of public money
well
it's a phenomenal waste of public money
for what what we gonna do fight russia
syria slightly
seriously our entire armed forces
air force navy army
would all together fit into villa park
dennis skinner said
dennis skinner said how much is this
going to cost us in 2014. hey said hague
said ukraine won't cost us anything
well some people have made hay of course
mike some people have uh some people
have piled up a personal fortune
the biden family in particular
yeah hunter garden yeah
coke head
in fact you know it's all about coke it
isn't the right sort of coke it's
another coke in fact
biden's son
pelosi's
and what's the guy who's the environment
secretary who ran for
president i've just forgotten his name
all the us politicians have sent their
sons to go and work in ukraine they're
it's a
it's klondike colony
unbelievable mike thanks for the call i
appreciate it um
on this day in which year did paris and
london
agreed to build a real link between
england and france i'm so old i can
remember it it later was named the
channel tunnel
was it
a 1964
b
or c
but you don't get that
answer
there is no trick other than hard work
and creative to care and recognizing
that duty is more important than love
the booming voice of robert maxwell an
arrogant man who used his publishing
empire to gain him power and influence
but in this shocking account never told
before in this way george galloway
recalls his first encounter with maxwell
it looked like a grizzly bear
advancing towards me and punches me with
these giant fists
like sides of ham right in the solar
plexus so hard that i literally bent
double
then after george exposed maxwell as a
crook in parliament
it was war
every one of his papers the daily mirror
then following the sunday mirror the
sunday people the daily record then a
few days later the sunday mail in
scotland even the european
which he then owned
all
over galloway
scottish daily news journalist ron mckay
was there
every night
presumably when they had a drink in them
he would boom over the tunnel
about the
the the the cretins the fools
the majority of the workforce believed
that he would take over and their jobs
would be secure but of course he didn't
he just disappeared and then
the millionaire newspaper publisher
robert maxwell is dead
what really happened did robert maxwell
jump
or was he pushed
it could be that he went out to as he
did
maturate over the side of the boat
i'm with glenn maxwell in that i leaned
towards the mata
this is maxwell the monster you said
what is my
secret i will let you and your viewers
know what it is i'm not attached to
property
consequently losing or gaining it means
nothing to me
george galloway
and the mother of all talk shows join us
at the college of knowledge where there
are no tuition fees
incredibly the answer is 1964.
it took 30 years from signing the first
agreement to finishing the channel
tunnel which opened in 1994
and a very fine thing it is two now
you've just been watching uh the series
it's terrific series if i say so myself
uh that myself and my editor ron mckay
have made maxwell the monster it's a new
three-part series you can get it now on
patreon it's only four pounds to become
a supporter and there's lots lots lots
more content more than you can
even imagine uh headed down the pipe to
my patreon channel it's uh
www.patreon.com
forward slash george galloway there's a
comment actually on patreon from
uh iron man records uh iron man i think
it is records iron man records uh the
three-part series makes a fascinating
watch thank you for all this i reckon
maxwell was pushed off the boat or if he
wasn't pushed he was prevented from
coming back on board once he was in the
water i find it hard to believe he fell
or committed suicide well you'll see in
the documentary uh my view on
that social media
rob says
hell no i'm not boycotting the
beijing olympics i want to see the
jamaican bobsled team pooling in a medal
is that still a possibility i know they
did it once uh d i support the athletes
i support the youngsters that become
inspired to become the next olympic
champions i don't support the regime but
let's not blame the athletes of those
that watch the games which uh which
regime do you mean boris johnson's
regime
i don't support the regime what's that
supposed to mean
graham 354 says why would anyone it's
completely stupid and i'm not really
interested in sport all this anti-russia
anti-china stuff is going to end us all
i'll let you in on a secret i'm not
watching it either but i'm definitely
not boycotting it i just have no
interest in winter sports
chika boom boom says african americans
are more under surveillance than chinese
and uyghurs combined and joanna nairi
says america supports all kinds of
dictators and warlords but that doesn't
mean we boycott sports events in that
country
and ima says the olympics are boring
anyway the olympic commission is also as
corrupt as hell
and david of england says no i'm not
boycotting them i'm utterly
disinterested honestly i'm sick and
tired of liberals pushing their liberal
norms narrative judging other countries
with no reference to their own hypocrisy
and historical crimes such as the
clearances the annexation of hawaii etc
very good david
and karen downer
says yes boycott not one minute spent
watching
and support pq
says china literally couldn't care less
about western propaganda i think i think
they are hoping a lot of us don't come
anyway the west pointing at china and
seeing human rights abuses is
unbelievable hypocrisy paul williams
says
boycott the world cup in qatar we'll
never do that and leroy drumm says for
what reason should they be boycotted
human rights abuse if that was the case
i'd have to boycott the olympics the
next time they're held in the usa
and liberty bell says
human rights abuses against the uyghurs
involvement in releasing a bio weapon on
the world
please
pollution and stripping other pollution
pollution china is polluting the world
oh my goodness
we had a 100 year start on them on that
and stripping other countries natural
resources we had 250 years start on them
on that liberty bell
killing wildlife for chinese medicine
we would never kill wildlife
not us tally
the treatment of hong kongers
you mean the former british colony of
hong kong
where nobody had a single democratic
right or ever cast a vote for anything
in the entire history of our rule of
hong kong a rule which i'll remind you
we took from them
in punishment of
their refusal to allow us to sell heroin
on chinese streets liberty bell you need
to
study more dear and james h says can't
sum it up much better than that one day
in the not too distant future we will
unfortunately pay the price for
appeasing the chinese communist party
jamesy why don't you get your tin hat on
and go out to the uh straits of taiwan
and
fight them
you're egypt and c real says west has
more human rights abuses than china both
in volume and frequency but go off i
guess and paul c says not on purpose
i just don't care and saber crosby
i better stop now i've got a lot of
callers but saber crossbass says i think
queen elizabeth will outlive charles
he's looked ropey for a few years now
sorry chuck
david is in new york let's hear from him
go ahead dave
uh hi yes um regarding the situation in
ukraine yeah yeah uh i i think as i see
it the ukrainian leader zilinski has
really no options let me let me go into
what i think are three three options
yeah uh under pressure from the
ukrainian white ring groups zlinski has
publicly rejected the ming secours which
ukraine had previously agreed to yeah
and if he now tries to return to those
agreements he risks being removed from
power by a right-wing coup yeah that's
one option but it's not good
if he stays with the current stalemate
the expense of maintaining a large of
offensive force on the border of the
breakaway regions over 100 000 troops in
a constant state of readiness
is an unsustainable expense given the
already ukrainian financial situation so
that option is not really good
if he launches an offensive against the
breakaway regions that really would
start a war with russia and the u.s
would label it as an invasion and then
they could say see we told you so
of course that would kill nordstrom 2
and the u.s oil industry would likely
become a major energy supplier it would
be very difficult if the ukrainian 100
000 troops invaded
uh regions which they have already
signed uh
to allow autonomy
that would be difficult to
portray as a russian invasion wouldn't
it right
and that's why the whole idea of
provocation uh uh but that but it's not
a good option i mean it's right it's
hard it's hard to justify it and and it
would it would it would it would benefit
the u.s oil industry because they become
a major energy supply to europe
replacing russia but it would it would
hurt the european economy again and
worse it would it would probably pretty
much destroy the almost already
distressed ukrainian economy so uh so
let's lenski has no good options if you
were to listen what would you do i'd go
back to being a comedian david that was
a great call thanks very much indeed
nick is in serbia they know a thing or
two about nato nick what would you like
to say yes hello george nice talking to
you and you sir
um look i would just like to add my
contribution and
i i really want to justify nato because
it's a really defensive force you know
that
tell that to the people in serbia where
you're calling from are you
exactly i am in serbia and i'm calling
for that and you see serbia is a super
power it was threatening the security of
nato
but this is a wind-up right this is a
wind-up up
but then you nearly had me there nick i
nearly opened up with the full katyusha
on you
but then again
we had uh
i i don't know if it will be absurd
blair i i'm not sure but not yet not if
we can stop it
okay
then we had two player who invented
humanitarian intervention yeah he
invited
he invented
the
so-called right to protect in his
chicago doctrine
in the time of clinton clinton was busy
behind the behind the desk at the time
but it was blair that authored it yeah
yeah yeah behind the desk i remember
that yes
um
but anyway uh so nato is truly a
defensive alliance there's no doubt
about that i i just wanted to
communicate that to you george just in
case we were otherwise
suspicious thanks very much uh indeed
for that
nick you can still vote on the poll are
you boycotting the beijing 2022 winter
olympics you can vote on my twitter feed
on my youtube
and on my telegram coming up is one of
my favorite guests tom mcgregor an
american in beijing
who's not just in beijing by the way but
was at the official opening ceremony now
i've already said to you bobsley and ice
skating and so on it's not my thing in
fact
you need a round ball to attract my
attention if it's not football or
snooker you'll probably not get me
watching it maybe boxing although
boxing's best days are over i think
but uh i certainly watched the opening
ceremony and it was utterly
stunning spectacular in the extreme uh
i've seen some great olympic openings
but i've never seen
anything like what we saw in beijing tom
mcgregor was lucky enough to be there
and he joins us now tom have i done it
justice it was breathtaking the opening
ceremony literally breathtaking
definitely certainly was very exciting i
was there i was witnessing
the entire opening ceremonies i was
graciously invited
to watch
and um it was just a spectacular scene i
it was absolutely amazing i definitely
was very happy to be there with my wife
to attend
you must have been lonely though you
must be the only foreigner out there
because everyone else is boycotting her
aren't they
no i saw quite a few diplomats in
attendance and
i was also with a group of uh many
foreigners uh we were also invited as
well so it was uh it wasn't i was not
lonely as the foreigner there were not
many americans though i'll admit that i
did not see many americans at this uh
opening ceremony although america sent a
team so it's a strange kind of boycott
isn't it
yeah very odd i mean if they really
believe there was a so-called genocide
why exactly do they allow the athletes
to participate but not the diplomats
this is really really strange
i'm not sure what is going on in their
minds but
definitely i was actually impressed by
the us athletes because their behavior
was very good
they looked uh very happy to be there
and they were very excited and i even
saw them dancing with some of the
chinese dancers there
uh
the
chinese will be bereft that joe biden
didn't come
i'm not sure he would have survived the
rigors of the journey
uh but vladimir putin was there in fact
he was guest number one
oh yeah oh yeah he was very popular a
lot of the presidents who came not only
just putin but apparently from i was
talking to some people recently
uh earlier today
and they were telling me that
they were closely monitoring a lot of
the leaders who are coming in to watch
because they're making some major trade
agreements with those leaders apparently
the ecuador president the argentina
president
a number of uh presidents in the south
america are having a very successful
trip not only just to watch the olympics
but also to uh engage and get closer to
china free trade agreements as well as
signing deals uh technology deals with
huawei to improve
the uh 5g uh wi-fi system in their
countries
do you know that
china is the largest trading partner now
of every single country in latin america
from mexico down to chile
and many of those countries leaders have
showed up for the olympics and they're
very pleased with those trade deals
because they know that they're
benefiting
what happens is they see the china model
and they want to sort of emulate the
china model to become very successful
now uh what kind of impact is it having
in beijing i presume it's spread out
uh widely in the country is it i mean
has it become
uh something of a an attraction for the
local people or are they just following
their career
yeah i mean it's a good question because
a lot of people are expecting the
chinese to be super excited uh it's sort
of like an event you got to realize that
this is happening during the spring
festival so for the chinese this is like
the christmas and new year's all rolled
into run
so they tend to be more focused on their
holidays i think they'll probably pay a
little bit more attention to the
olympics when they get back to work
is it on television though i mean is it
can you watch it live
yeah yeah what's the standard of chinese
television by the
way uh yeah it's on chinese television
uh and many people are watching that uh
a lot of times they they're very
interested in the skating speed skating
is very popular here in china in fact
china have got
an american citizen in their team don't
they a girl
half chinese half american she prefers
to compete for china
sure
well i mean obviously she has the right
to do so uh in the past american
uh u.s athletes used to recruit
teammates from other countries so this
is not in a new unusual situation
so i mean it's not like this is a rare
shocking moment i think it's just that
what happens is that you shocked them at
fox news tom i'll tell you that yeah i
heard i heard that they they devoted an
entire segment into denouncing it
i think sometimes tucker carlson he has
uh does not have a good understanding of
china i would love for him to uh invite
me
uh on his show so i can have a china
conversation with them like i have with
you because i don't think tucker carlson
is real familiar with the real china
so
to your lovely chinese family how's the
new year been for you
oh very relaxing uh this year has been
much more relaxing than before i think
it's because the olympics have made a
good spirit in china and that uh it
looks like we're sort of on the final
days of the coronavirus and i think
people are ready to start moving on and
get back to their regular normal lives
so this is sort of the start of the
return to normal
okay thank you very much tom most kind
of you to join us sorry about the hour
uh are you boycotting the beijing
olympics yes 46 no 54 on twitter
yes 22 on youtube
no 78 on youtube telegram yes 30 no
70 1 200 votes cast and breaking news
senegal have won the africa cup of
nations for the first time on penalties
that was muhammad salla versus sadio
manny and sadio manny won i think egypt
won it the last time did manny get the
winner how fantastic
is that he'll be he'll be popular back
in liverpool with mohamed salah
john lee perry
says apart from charles wanting it for
her why would anyone want to be called
queen
after queen elizabeth ii and goberwala
says george as a commoner you have zero
say in the matters of the monarchy of
britain capisce no capisce brother no
capisce i'm a free man with a voice and
a platform and i will speak my truth
whatever you
think
of it
gareth walter says george you are the
king there you go
george you are the king
of truth and integrity long live king
george gareth that's so kind of you
unless you meant the mad king george
a nasty says there should be no more
royalty this is not the dark aegis and
zenzamilla says we need to start a
petition to get a referendum on becoming
a republic i will do
i will lead that campaign i've already
told you
scouse allah says we shouldn't have a
king or queen but i fear that we always
will
we as a country seem to be content with
a family receiving
millions of pounds of taxpayers money
for literally nothing whilst millions of
people starve and freeze this winter and
colin says
talking about this today actually
apparently the cost of having a monarchy
is break even
although i have not seen the research to
back it up you won't see it calling you
need to read the right honorable norman
baker's book
it's called
and what do you do
and it is
the whole case
against the system
of monarchy
and mr grumpy says
flag of united kingdom nothing to do
with you if her majesty the queen says
so then yes
why are you grump are you
like 14 grumpy
or do you think you're living in the
18th century
if her majesty the queen says
grow up man
and dinkle says absolutely no sorry
enough i can understand the queen has
done our job as she was told to in the
olden days but in this modern world we
need to move on we don't need royals
it's really grotesque when people are
struggling so much
and neg says pretty sure she's no longer
with us g along with most of the monarch
what's wrong with you conspiracy
theorists
uh stop uh dissing monarchy would you
rather have a plastic president says
kevin i've done that one
uh
and uh
some of these are actually unprintable
unread outable i must say let's go to
kenny and acton instead yeah kenny is
someone for the money
good evening george good evening brother
how are you i'm i'm good man i'm
actually in high holborn just now i'm
currently working
so i've got my motorcycle park and i'm
looking at her right now and she's
looking beautiful because i just
polished that earlier on with mr sheen
and i shammy no not the queen your
motorcycle
that's right my honda i'll tell you what
you meant you were looking at the queen
and you polished her with a chamois that
would have been lesser that would have
been less a major stay what kind of
motorbike have you got ken
i've got a cherry red honda pcx125
well that is
a lovely thing although ever since the
watching the bridge over the river kwai
i've never been able to buy a a japanese
motor
call me old-fashioned
all right well do you know what i named
her i named her ronda because she's a
red honda and uh because i love the
beach boys as well it's a very nice uh
name cherry red is a lovely color i've
got a cherry red motor car
uh but uh a cherry red motorbike that
would be quite the thing and you wear
the leathers and all that don't you
not just wear jeans but i've got a
protective motorcycle jacket though but
i really should the thing i really need
to get is gloves because if you fall off
the road at 30 miles an hour
uh your palms are coming off your hands
and i'm start i'm led to believe that's
even worse than breaking a leg you know
yeah i i i can well uh i can well i
really need to get your
now you're a legend kenny and there's
another legend just appeared on the
other people
so give us a quick song will ya
okay here we go
this is from the film fonunaka pilco oh
great movie by the way great movie yes
good
here we go
pedro the boo was a killer
king of the blue fighter arena
he'd wipe up the floor with each brave
matador then have muttered or shoe for
his dinner
he heard the crowd shouting holy
but he met his master that day
[Music]
the boo fighter was a lady
and it was true love at first sight
her red cape was waving but pedro was
shaving he wanted to date her that night
pedro the boo he was smitten
first time the love bug had bitten
he once was on my bullet wild and a bad
brew but now he was mild as a kitten
the crowd there were starting to hiss
but pedro just wanted to kiss
the blue fighter was a lady
and pedro he liked what he saw
fantastic
[Music]
bravo bravo kenny excellent rendition
i'm only clearing off the line because
there's another legend norman bristow go
ahead norma
hello george not much time you couldn't
follow that could you well it's about
music i'm talking about okay and that's
singing and i'm gonna talk about music
um
play days were banned um those young
people they look good and fantastic i
never listened yeah to them one was 20
and the oldest was 25. makes you feel
old norma
oh
mama do you know let me give you a fun
fact
the beatles broke up 52 years ago
52 years before that
was the first world war
that puts a lot of things in perspective
doesn't it
well i suppose but to get to the point i
was trying to make george go ahead
is that um my son he does um
he actually he's on a radio program in
bristol and he interviewed a lot of
young groups
but i do feel though that the um
classical composers are rarely mentioned
now
on
private passions today
they have this lady barbara taylor
bradford and she had a beautiful lot of
music puccini's favorite operas
tchaikovsky swan lake
and beethoven's moonlight scenario
and you know
it needs promotion as well it's a sort
of inverse snobbery i think about
classical music well i was i played in
an orchestra and we play uh we play
radio 3 we play classic fm all the time
far from prejudice against i'm
prejudiced in favor of it norma yeah and
did you get just to get this in bob
marley would have been 77 yesterday
that's right and he was asked if he'd
become a rich man he said how do you
define riches yeah do you think
possessions means you're rich
oh he's a great guy what a great man
taken from us uh far too young
so happy birthday in the sky
bob marley no woman no cry uh is one of
my uh favorites the best to you norma
thank you
your great husband
uh i hope the two of you see out this
winter comfortably as spring is
headed our way
it's time up for me though
but uh god willing i'll be here next
week at the same time in the same place
it's been marvelous i hope you come back
and see me again
[Music]
you